Do I sound okay?
Do I look okay?
Like I'm such a mess right now.
Hello, hello.
Any echo?
Is it echoey?
Is it better?
Oh, I sound.
Okay, no echo.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, okay.
I sound the same.
Okay.
So I got, oh my God, I got soundproofing done.
So, um, that's why I had to, um, I had to push back a little bit.
little bit so well it was not more than a little bit but I got soundproofing done um in my office so um that's why I had to push it back because it did take a while so that means if I get a noise like we had we had this thing where it's like this little rectangular thing and there's like a little fluffy mic thing where it checks like the decibel of um of like oh it's a little bit of echo don't worry I'll just throw some I'll just grab a buy a carpet or something by a rug or something um so so you know like those like things that uh you can check how loud you are the decibel thing so if i get a noise complaint no no i don't know they're like right up to my door or so they're either the it might have been like a goddamn plot twist and like um and my the people that were actually complaining was like my my like downstairs neighbor or some shit like i don't at that point because I can't obviously I can't soundproof the floor so like if I get a noise complaint uh from somebody it had it's
like a plot shows it's actually my downstairs neighbor um it was never it wasn't even my next door neighbor it was actually my downstairs neighbor like so so if that's the case then I'm fucked uh so yes I finally got soundproof done um So that means I will be able to,
I will be able to do my 5 a.m.
streams, I hope.
I hope.
But also, I was struggling a bit because I actually broke my monitor.
I broke one of my monitors.
So I'm working with two monitors for today.
But don't worry, I do have another monitor.
I do have an Xpair third monitor for just in case the monitor.
breaks um it was like it was very unfortunate um i think i asked i was i had to like um sorry i'm like my my mind is so frazzled right now so i can't do words right now i can't like fucking i also hit okay guys don't be too don't be like are you okay like do you think i was like don't you please also might have hit my head a little bit um the top of my head a little bit because i hit I bumped my head into something but I'm okay I think I'm okay
I'm okay because I was like try okay so what happened was I was trying to take my monitor I was trying to well not my monitor I was trying to like connect something to the back of my desk and then I hit my um I hit the the corner the monitor like hit my the top of my head because I was trying to unplug something um that's not why it broke though that's not I don't know maybe that's why i broke because my head was just so fucking solid um um anyway so uh so my monitor can't turn on anymore it turns on but you know like the fail safe where it would like automatically turn off right away so so uh so whenever i try to turn the monitor on it just goes and then it just turns off right away like i don't fucking know what to do so we're running on two monitors right now until like i get my third monitor plugged back in uh so yep that's really it it's not i don't know i tried i was like maybe it's the plugs maybe it's like the cable i tried like three different cables it's none of it worked so
um i think it i don't know maybe it's something inside fucked up because it just instantly turns off on itself so i do have another I have another monitor right now as my main monitor so um it's very weird because it's a it's different from my usual monitor uh because at first it was like oh do you want to run it the recommended resolution which was like 3000 or some shit and I was like sure and I clicked on the 3000 and um and then like everything enlarged you guys were like what the fuck do you mean dokey okay so and all my stuff on my OBS so I'll show you guys what I mean so um obviously the oh wait what okay there you go obviously this is the recommended resolution that they wanted me to put in and then where did I go where did I go on the OBS but then if I put on the one below that um I get
So, I don't want to, I don't know, I can't be bothered resizing all, because I actually have to resize everything if I want to, if I want to do the recommended resolution.
And I can't be bothered.
I'm so used to what everything looks like.
So, you know, like, I don't know, it fucks with me if like one thing changes, like that size wise, or like if I'm like a little bit to the left, it like fucks with me a lot.
where I was for so long that like I just don't like change I just don't like change change is bad Anthony thank you for the super chat thank you thank you peak v2 replace peak game I'm gonna love this eating thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh damn that noggin is dense hollow but dense blue to damn my hair up thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um so I don't know I don't there's so many things I'm all over the place right now I had to wake up so early too for the soundproofing and stuff so I got the consultation for sound like the quotes and consultation the day before and I also had to wake up super early for that and they're like we can do it get it done tomorrow I was like sweet and then and then obviously I have to wake up super early again to have them do the soundproofing and everything so I'm all over the place right now I'm not I'm not mentally there and I also hit my head too like I'm okay I'm okay um I'm okay guys,
don't worry But yeah, so So I'm just like all over the place By the way, some people were like Is she gonna play the censored or the non-censored Version of this patch So the thing is No, there's no bump I like touched the top of my head And there's no like,
it's not like you know there's no bump on my head so i think i'm okay um but anyway so apparently there is a censored and a non-censored version and then um i asked one of my friends who's like fucking obsessed with dispatch right now because i was like okay how bad is non-censored and then they were like oh yeah at the beginning like i was like okay do i see an actual penis because i That's fine,
but I need a no, do I see?
Is it just there?
Because that's when YouTube's like, no, no, no.
Because boobs, for some reason, boobs, because I don't know if you guys know this on YouTube, but it allows you to see certain nudity because they'll just be like, it's educational or it's just part of the game.
But the moment there's a dick, that's when YouTube's like, no.
Peepies are not allowed.
So, so I'm like, okay, how bad is it?
So, because apparently dicks aren't educational.
So, so my friend was like, showed me a clip of the first, I guess, like 20 seconds, like the intro, where you see the back of the peepie.
And I was like, that's not bad.
wet like it's these and then my friend was like oh yeah no that's not the worst part no it shows the full-on pee-pee later on i'm like oh okay that's bad that's bad guys we the thing is i can't have another video get striped r18 guys you know what happens um uh but no the thing is the thing is i'm pretty sure i don't know jacksepticeye's rod might be r18 because you know what striped as R18,
my Garfield, sorry, Docafield, Jim, don't come after me.
It's a parody.
My Docafield Halloween stream got marked as R18.
So I can't do it again.
Because if you have too many streams marked as R18, YouTube actually fucks with your algorithm.
So we can't do that again.
I don't want down on me um so i'm pretty sure like i think get away with this on twitch but like on youtube like i don't think i can get away with it uh but uh but i think i don't know if jack's vibe yeah jack i'm tight with him like that i caught him by his first name uh i don't know if jack septica's uh stream of uh of dispatch um was marked as r.n 18.
I'm not sure.
Can anyone vouch?
Sorry, my bro Sean.
Oh yeah.
God, I'm sorry.
Sean, I forgot.
His name isn't Jack.
He likes it when we call him Jack.
So is his stream or video?
I don't know if he does the let's play.
Marked R 18 because I'm not bad dealing with that.
I'm not dealing with r18 guys it is but i also think i also think he got away with he gets away with it because you know um i also oh okay it's a video okay i also think he gets away with it because he's literally like og youtube and he's part of the game and i think if i try to stream non-censored um i don't know how You take me.
He is a bigger streamer.
I don't think I matter to YouTube.
There's birds and bees.
Thank you.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Other than that, I have no idea what Dispatch really is.
I've heard people saying that it's sort of like Telltale.
It's like a Telltale game, so it's just watching cutscenes and walking around, which is great.
I don't have to do much.
with extra steps so that's cool that's fine i think i don't know if i'm gonna do all the way till the end um uh so yeah and apparently it's made by telltale devs too so the only also the other thing that i know about this batch is um you mean temporary planet but you plan forever i've been saying that like like at least once a day that's like that's my new That's my vocal stim.
It's so good.
I just love how she's like bitch you plan forever It's so good.
I don't even know the context.
I just love like the delivery for that is just so fucking good I don't even know what's going on.
I'm just like bitch you plan forever and I just keep saying that I don't know I would say it randomly too.
I would just be like I'd just be whacking daddy.
I'd be like fuck you be temporary blinded bitch you plan forever just by myself just it's just it rolls off the tugs so well it's my new brain ride like
yeah so um like it's just i don't know it i just love i don't know i just fucking love that that line is the delivery is just that good uh i'm actually brainrider yeah i thought you were addicted to ira gotcha papa smirk thank you for this super chat thank you thank you not in the expense of my job this is my career i can't i can't get my channel like this is what shuts my channel down like a random pp uh simple minded thank you for the super chat thank you thank you joki think of the possibilities 18 plus hell yeah let's go thank you the super chat thank you thank you anyway so that is all the things I know about this patch,
so, uh, sorry, I apologize for starting late today, um, but, you know, I finally got soundproofing, I went through a lot of technical difficulties, but, you know, I finally got soundproofing, though, so, like, you know, good for future streams, at least,
yeah, um, um, so, yeah, we're just gonna, we're gonna try it out today, I don't know if I'm gonna do, um, do all the episodes, I looked up that, you know, it's like eight hours long and I don't know if I'm ready for an eight hour playthrough For today,
so we'll see if we get to episode four and then I'm like, you know what I'm ready Then then we'll maybe we'll do eight hours So we'll see if I we'll see we'll see anyway Also another reason why I want to play this game is for man bat for furry of the he is the he is the wild the wild dark horse for the furry of the year contender uh for those who don't know the context so every year there so for those who need context don't worry i explained this before on the batman stream which was very appropriate uh let me pull up the year they would every year um they would select one furry for the hot furry of the year uh and right now it is between man bat and and i don't remember it's another wolf it's it's it's another wolf i don't fucking know so apparently man bat Charlie,
Boys Critical, is like the one to end the cycle, the wolf cycle.
And everyone's trying to figure out who is going to be 2025 Fury of the Year.
Will it be another dog?
Or will it be a bat?
The Raid of Wolf.
Will the Raid of Wolfmen end this year?
you with the super chat thank you thank you so we're gonna find out if the cycle will end so i vote for charlie's persona so that's the other thing i know about um about this fact the craziest thing is that i knew about man bad because i saw this pn because i saw that viral tweet on twitter being like please end the wolf cycle We must vote for ManBat to be this year's furry of the year.
And that's how I knew about ManBat.
And I was like, wait, that guy's from this batch out.
That's the only reason why I knew about ManBat.
It's like, break the cycle.
Damn, the sonar situation is crazy, guys.
I also love all the videos.
I love Spineapples.
If you guys know who Spineapple is, she's like a really famous animator for TF2 before.
Like she would make like lots of amazing, dumb, funny Team Fortress 2 animations.
And then she did like one for where she like basically took like moist critical clips and then like animated to like the Mechamac situation.
It's crazy.
It's so good.
I'll link it to you guys who doesn't want to see it.
Spine, I love Spineapples.
i love her uh her animation i used to watch that shit like young here you go for those who want to watch the video i love this video but let me make sure that uh all right here you go that animation is so funny if anyone wants to check it out um takado thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it's my birthday weekend and we got doki dispatch always a good time watching doki playing a superhero related game especially because it would change based on her decisions.
Do you think I can get a quick happy birthday?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jakarta.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yeah, yippee.
All right, guys, let's play some Dispatch.
Oh, God, it's so weird having two monitors right now.
All right, I got to move this to my...
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is so weird.
I got to figure out how to...
I have to move all of this.
All right.
Thing is, I'll be changing this monitor, the main monitor, to a different monitor again, too.
So it's going to be all over the place.
All right.
Don't block my dispatch.
Dispatch.
All right.
This is my, uh, Doki is my blonde blazer.
Who's blonde blazer?
I'm definitely going to make the worst choices ever, and you're all going to yell at me.
I can feel it.
Because, like, whenever I make choices, I'm going to.
I'm like, what's the funniest choice?
Not the, what's the funniest choice out there?
Not the one that makes the most sense or like trying to be about empathy or some shit.
Who the fuck cares about that?
I'm, I had to be a good person in real life, okay?
Like, why would I be a good person in a video game?
That's what real life is for.
It's video games was for me to do the things I'm not supposed to do in real life.
This is gonna be good.
Sombard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's rape.
Let my intrusive thoughts go wild because there's no consequences.
All right.
I hope any of my sound guide people are alive.
I did start a little late than usual.
All right.
Settings.
Okay, quick time, events, unlimited hacking attempts, language, English.
Okay, we gotta get subtitles in.
All right, on speaker's name.
Yes, please.
I might forget who they are.
I need background.
No, I don't need it.
Replace licensed music.
We don't care about profanity.
I need visual censorship, though.
Like, other than...
We don't care about...
I don't care about like license music at best they take my monetization, but like visual censorship I ain't getting like R18 here Nathan and or do not welcome to tomato farm welcome well.
Yeah, peepie deny we're denying the peepies We're We draw the line with that we get that out of here We revoked the peepies All right, play All right, nice.
That's like, yeah, that's basic.
Oh, wait, maybe.
Maybe we should have a little bit of a background, actually.
Yeah, actually, we'll have, we'll, fuck it.
We can sort of read that.
All right.
Okay, visual.
Yep, everything is good.
Yep, this all looks good.
All right.
active is he swiping what like i don't know what you're okay we'll do be part oh yeah be part of the action yeah of course like we're not watching a movie here i mean technically we're half watching a movie but this is apparently um this is apparently uh uh made have the some of the same devs as uh telltale people so that's why it feels very like telltale you guys were wondering in collaboration with critical oh critical row collaborated on this obviously i love him he's my dad okay what does that mean does it say what that's me right i'm the main character when you add obviously it feels a little less obvious so i'll ask again how do you yeah i was gonna say is matt mercer in this it's as if maybe it's a little more complicated then you feel i didn't he's it's completely understandable look he's gone yeah who the fuck cares oh so game needs up these okay let me up the game a little bit alright let me know if this is better he's fucking dead that's the most gone you can be just so
sensitive listen if I didn't love him we wouldn't be here right we don't have to get into it oh wait I'm bleeding why am I bleeding Bro, why the fuck is my dog licking my nose blood?
Ugh, shit.
My nose is bleeding.
Thought I was getting emotionally snotty.
No, it's probably from when I kicked him in my face.
Oh, shit.
What?
I was like, Oh my God, am I okay?
Did I get a concussion?
Okay, more upbeats.
Don't worry, I got you.
Yeah, thanks for reminding me.
So, here's what's gonna happen.
He's letting down.
Yeah, I noticed that.
What?
You're gonna tell me where Shroud is or the FPS guy just turn on twitch Soothing good.
Wait, am I a superhero?
You're pretty easy to talk to but the I was like the Shroud guy on twitch I'm not telling you shit you fucking loser see this is more like how I thought this was this is still super quiet Bro Shroud kills like I know he does in game, but 100.
All right.
Oh, dialogue boost.
Okay, how about that?
That should work.
I knew it.
I knew that he was aim was way too good, guys.
Like, I hope he fucking spanks your little daddy as you bitch ass.
Yeah.
Are we outside?
Windy up here tonight.
Why are we outside?
I'm not a good person.
Smells like outside smells.
Oh, shit.
I have neighbors.
Use your inside voice and just tell me where Shroud is.
Okay, okay.
Steel mill.
Llewellyn's steelworks, okay?
Fuck.
You sure about that?
Yes, please.
That's all I know.
Stop screaming.
I want to get Batman to do stuff like this.
Hey, I will pull you up if you quiet the fuck down.
Oh, shit.
Okay, you don't bite the hat of someone that's carrying you.
Let him drop.
Fuck it.
Sir, if you want something to scream about, He gave me the intel, right?
Goodbye.
Yay.
Oh, he's alive?
Oh, shit.
Hey, I ruined a perfectly good mattress to make sure you didn't die.
Okay, you're welcome.
Okay, to be fair, he already gave me the information so that I don't need to keep him alive.
Oh, maybe a superhero is killed.
We won't get a lot of villains.
Like, that's all I'm saying.
Maybe we'll have less villains if we started killing villains.
How is he going to remember that?
I technically saved his life.
I put him in a mattress.
Bring the music down.
Sure, I'll bring the music down.
music.
I'll put it at 90.
I might... Do I even have superpowers, or I'm just like...
Do I just built this mecha suit for myself?
No need for Arkham.
You got super jokie, but you're getting rid of all the super villains.
Exactly!
Jakarta.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
What happens if I don't do my quick time event?
Okay, I...
Jesus Christ, we're doom scrolling right now.
Like, I'm like, is this necessary?
Like, I don't keep, please.
Am I just Iron Man?
All I'm saying is that, oh, my game crashed.
Okay, well, I found out apparently if you don't do your quick time event, your dispatch crashes.
Okay.
okay all right i guess we go back in i who would have thought it couldn't do that you have said thank you put in the super chat thank you thank you my best friend was boomed by a crazy avian bounty hunter in front of me to do super villain numbers the first thing i'm doing is making that my super villain origin no i have to oh my god okay all right here we go again it's just when you add obviously it feels a little less obvious so all right i'll ask again all right feel about your father okay so maybe it's a little more he's got i mean i could have asked something new it's completely understandable i could skip it in the scene select it didn't let me look he's gone that's a bit of an understatement yeah i can't skip it so well he's more than try drop him again it's like i never dropped him the most gone Just so sensitive.
Listen, if I didn't love him, we wouldn't be here, right?
We don't have to get into it.
Oh, wait, he was trying to give me a therapy session, too.
Why would I be trying to find a man who killed him if I didn't love him?
Why would I be doing any of this?
Ugh, shit.
My nose is bleeding.
Thought I was getting...
Yeah, twice as though that I don't regret it.
It's probably from when I kicked you in the face.
He did kick me.
Here's what's gonna happen.
of this building and you're going to tell me yeah just to show you guys i i still i don't regret it come on i thought we were having a breakthrough hey we did you know we're being a real piece of you're pretty easy to talk to but the only oh yeah i found out on twitter apparently um none of all the videos are pre-rendered um they're all pre-rendered so you none of the models are in any of the files and all the gooners were like so depressed Are we outside?
Wendy up here tonight.
Why are we outside?
They couldn't get the models.
So all the Gooners were still sad.
They're like, what's the point?
I have neighbors.
Use your inside voice and just tell me.
That's messed up.
All I have to say is Gooners make the game alive.
Steel mill.
Llewellyn Steel works, okay?
Fuck.
You sure about that?
Yes, please.
That's all I know.
Stop screaming.
God damn it.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, I will pull you up.
Sam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Game was like, okay, if you don't want to play the game, then there won't be a game for you to play.
I doomed scroll too far.
No, no, no, no, no.
Of course.
Of course I'll still drop him.
I ruined a perfectly good mattress to make sure you didn't die.
Okay.
That's crazy that I didn't really.
realize um that the main character is voiced by uh Jesse Jesse I'm sorry what's his real name I don't even remember because it it sort of sounds like him but also does not sound like him yeah Aaron Paul yeah oh yeah I was gonna up the volume a little bit more all right let me know if that's better
Jesse, we need a dispatch.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
I didn't like him in Invincible.
I think his voice acting in Invincible was like pretty dull.
Fun.
Yeah, he was the Pyreplex.
I wasn't like a fan of his voice acting Pyreplex.
Alright, sorry.
No more Doom scrolling.
He was really good in Bojack, yeah.
Apparently, I can't doom scroll anymore.
Oh, shit.
What happens if I don't?
Still did it.
Still got it.
Thanks, game.
I think they just didn't animate a different scene for it.
I mean, it still worked.
What happens if I...
all right holy shit he's here will i get shot oh shit oh fuck i should have hit back i should have defended myself i thought he would defend himself for me
so fight back i thought the game will help me yes it's time to make new mottoes on blender uh no thank you the super chat thank you thank you my actions have consequences no way oh w-a-s-d am i supposed to go finish this hello uh input code oh this is easy it's like hacking 101 baby's first hack oh and the swish okay there you go some notes allowed all right next okay where do i go oh i have to re-hack this okay oh my god this is so easy there you go oh i grab this just one more oh i have to go back god damn it i knew i would have done the bottom first God,
I'm so good at hacking.
This clearly reflects IRL hacking too.
What am I waiting for?
Waiting on final breach?
Where is it?
Breaching?
What am I waiting?
Oh, shit.
The mouse button is above me.
I'm doing it.
Sorry, I was looking I was looking down.
Hacking is so easy, guys.
It's so easy.
Can I die in this game?
Like, if I fail too many QuickTime events?
It's over, Shroud.
Can I get a copy of that video when we're through here?
Because it's over, Shroud.
That's right.
Nice to watch that back at a different angle.
That's right, Shroud.
I'm aiming for you.
I'll be the next FPS streamer.
Killer and you come in here with that lame shit.
Yeah, where the fuck is Shroud?
Yeah, where is Shroud?
Is he still streaming our creators?
After our conversation, I asked him about your dad.
Fun little tidbit.
He was very well hydrated.
Turns out right after Shroud shot him in the chest, your dad pissed his pants.
Bet you didn't know that, huh?
Yes, sir, he's too busy playing our creators right now.
He still had enough time to know how absolutely fucked he was.
Just pissed himself like a little bitch.
It was like so much.
Hunter's stomping.
Because your dad was wearing shorts.
Hey, just kept...
I get it.
Oh, shit.
Like, foot...
Oh, I should have stomped him.
If I knew...
Oh, this is the Mechamand situation.
Wait, I'm mecha man.
I understand now.
Sorry, I didn't think I didn't need to waste a perfectly good mattress to break your fall.
Perfectly good.
I assume that it comes to the thing was already in the dumpster.
Can we just skip to the part where you...
How is he alive?
Oh, God.
Oh, there's the PPC.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, there.
There it is.
cool you uh that's a kind of clever super villain there you can call me toxic okay there it is so many levels for you yeah no that's the point that's that that's nice trout's augments are pretty good when normie oh yeah no yeah no no we would not be safe on youtube yeah no if i had yeah no we would have not been safe
It's just...
I just...
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, I got help.
I got to help him out, bro.
Thank God we're just...
That's right.
Why don't I just rip it off?
I mean, it's just swinging there.
It's just...
Yeah, why don't I...
Why don't I just rip it off?
Fuck.
Don't let it...
Hit you.
Oh my god, you're right, I could- Oh shit, whoops!
You're right, I could have just like swung it around too.
That's against the man coat.
Just start using it as a rope.
Figures.
All right.
Bam!
Piece of shit.
Oh man, this fight scene is pretty good though.
Wait, it's just Jello.
Or do they, do all of them just let it swing around like that?
Oh, this way.
Black sensor clock.
Oh shit!
all right bye-bye yeah one less super villain oh shit where's his dick see he lives guys but why is it like just in my face oh no wait it's spreading my mecha suit
Oh, shit.
Wait, what am I doing?
I'm rebooting?
I'm alt F4ing?
Alt F4 and reboot.
Oh, this is looking bad.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, you're very...
Oh, I'm a barrier?
Nice.
Wait, would I have died if I didn't?
didn't do that.
I'm overclocking.
Don't worry.
Shroud!
He came back from Arc Raiders!
Hey, Shroud!
Welcome back!
So, what do you got left on them shields?
I said 40% He stopped his stream.
He says you're down to 28.
And he is not wrong about these things.
Good news, buddy.
Trout says he just wants the Astral Pulse, which we all know isn't really yours anyway.
Unless he missed the opportunity to not get Trout and voice Trout.
Oh, there he is.
Your dad killer.
System check.
Calculate the damage per second hitting shields.
Then tell me how many seconds I need to divert Astral pulse energy to Raka boosters.
Animation's really good.
Also, sound guy.
I hope all the sound is good so far.
What?
Pulse power to the boosters.
It won't work.
This is a limited time offer, dude.
What's up?
Ignore him.
Villains always lie.
Oh, shit.
No.
I don't give a fuck, okay?
I'm just the messenger here.
He says you're not calculating that shift stuck to your legs, dumbass.
I wanted to hear more of the Dala.
See, everything's fine.
See, I told you he was lying.
Okay, but why censor the ass?
This ass is fine.
As is technically PG.
Oh,
oh, do I have a tracker?
Or like, oh.
He don't get to have cake and eat it too.
Stop fear!
that's fine he's the main character dispatch bye that mechaman situation was crazy though oh hey are we watching tick-tock now it was just over four months ago images like this were recorded across the Southland videos flooded social media and our newsroom showing what many thought to be oh the death of
Oh, like, that's his dad.
A Mecha Man has protected Los Angeles.
Built by an ordinary civilian with no superpowers.
This first suit was dubbed by some fans as Mecha Man Prime.
That's his dad.
Three generations of pilot.
Oh, that's his grandpa.
Their identities have secret.
Have given everything to protect this community, including their lives.
After the tragic passing of Prime, the next Mecha Man, known as Astral, teamed up with a star-studded superhero group.
known as the Brave Brigade.
Leading to an unprecedented period of peace in the Southland position.
After years of loyal service, tragedy struck again.
When Shroud, a former Brave Brigade member turned villain, killed the pilot of Mecha Man in cold blood.
But yet again, as hope was lost, a third generation of Mecha Man emerged.
A Mecha Man for the modern era.
A bulwark against organized crime in the greater Los Angeles area.
earlier today don't worry did he continue his bloodline
oh he's fine he didn't die he's literally right here about my health and the state of the mecha man suit just build another suit speculation to rest the suit has been damaged beyond my ability to repair so i will be stepping back from super just build another suit what do you mean does this mean you're finished can you repair Yeah!
How badly were you hurt?
One at a time, please.
Ashley Reines, San Pedro Daly, do you have anything to say to your fans?
The public outpouring, the vigils, a lot of them were worried you would wake up.
I did my best.
I suppose I want them to know I did my best.
I worked as long as I could, as hard as I could.
Oh, he's so fucking depressed.
That's all anyone can do.
Next question.
Chris Stratton, Torrance Tribune.
Does this mean you're retiring as Mecha Man?
Word on the street is you're done so you 100 years old.
Why are you talking like that?
Answer the question buddy boy.
Are you retiring?
My readers need the skinny and I aim to deliver.
No comment.
I'm not looking to comment on that just yet.
That's the only skinny I can give you.
No comment.
You deserve my comment after that.
You saw me no comment.
Just one more.
Preferably someone.
No headline for you.
Charles Kingsley, South Bay Signal.
So, Shroud kills your father, goes to jail 50 years, breaks out, and immediately dupes you into a trap where he destroys the Mega Man suit and puts you in a coma for months.
I can't get over the fact that his name is Shroud.
It's like, Shroud, didn't it?
Holy fuck, Shroud?
First, Shroud did what?
Why didn't Shroud kill you?
You haven't been conscious for months.
It'd be easy money taking you out.
Okay, Shroud wanted the Astral Pulse.
Bro, Shroud got real toxic.
I'm not sure I mattered much right you're unimportant which leads me to my next question Most heroes avenge their family you did the opposite you killed their legacy what how disappointed would your dad be if he were here right now I'm still alive.
I could go back.
I'll attack.
Fuck you You know what?
Who cares?
I'm retired anyway
My reputation is...
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
On international news, dude?
Of course.
But there's two issues there.
He clearly has nothing left to lose.
I'm technically retired.
Yay, alcoholism, dude.
No one was stepping in.
Yes, I was...
Bro, I wouldn't fucking have.
Like I said, I have nothing to lose here.
That's...
Hey, I was watching that.
Bro, I'm broke.
I have no TV.
Are you assholes?
I was fucking watching that.
Hey, who are you calling assholes, asshole?
I'll handle this idiot.
Keep loading.
We're out of here in 30.
And who the fuck are you?
Yeah, you go go fucking hoax.
Ranger.
Someone with nothing to lose.
I beat up a reporter.
I can beat you up too.
Which is probably bad news for you.
Well, with nothing you have, you're about to lose again.
Whatever the case, I'm enough to deal with.
I'm a whole boat Ranger.
God damn it.
Look, you're hurt.
You're not thinking straight.
Wait, which one?
Okay, right.
Someone who knows which hand every punch is coming from.
I'm a punch with my right.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
That's right, I still have legs, though.
Oh, shit!
I can't continue my legacy.
Oh.
What the?
The fight back.
Eh.
I did it.
it guys that guy i threw he landed on the roof right yeah totally all good you hi i'm blonde blazer i work over at superhero dispatch network also i can't believe it you can't romance the mad bad he's 100 straight that's also the only deal breaker for me i'm just a corporate zero for higher you're the real deal i found that out as well I'm so sad.
I don't think infamous is the same as famous, but...
Oh, God.
Your arm.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, there's yours.
Diva is 0% upshade.
That's your assistant.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Usually dislocates the other way.
Have you done this before?
Okay, but have you done this before?
Because maybe...
Oh, God.
Oh, gay.
Wow.
That's, uh...
That's okay.
Thank you.
One of them is on that roof.
Yeah, Mega Man, Mega Man.
You look like you can only romance two people, and they're both women.
What makes you say that?
I could just romance all of them, you know?
I have nothing to lose.
I should be able to romance any character.
It's lame.
I should be able to hook up with everyone.
so true where's my hair around but you know what yeah thank you for the pocket the ships thank you thank you i think vizzy's rubbing off on me who uh someone i work with it's yeah
but this feels like a challenge that feels like a challenge yeah Do it.
Chug, chug, chug.
Love is in the air.
Don't worry about keeping up.
Something to do with the powers.
Yeah, I should be the romance shroud.
My daddy killer.
What is that sentence?
Hey, you should give yourself more credit to do what you did for as long as you did.
Especially without superpowers.
Not true.
What do you call this?
Oh, God.
I can fix that one for you too.
No thanks.
I like this one.
Thank you.
Yeah, to Toxic Yowie.
Enemies to lovers, exactly.
So, this game would have been perfect if I could romance everyone.
Millions?
So you'll understand when the check comes.
You're serious.
Millions?
Yeah, I basically burned through my entire inheritance, keeping it going.
The last couple years have just been duct tape and sheer determination.
What, like, what is this job?
Why did you do it?
What did he say to you?
Sacrifice everything to be a superhero to the point of financial...
Oh my god, it's like Batman if he's broke.
Or like Iron Man if he had no money.
It's like I've beenced.
The only thing I'm good at is what I stream.
Now that's a sad sentence.
Come on, that can't be true.
I guess it could be true.
So are you...
He's broke, man.
Yeah, yeah, I should probably be switching to water Good, because I was hoping after some drinks to loosen you up I could learn a little more about you And if all that went well This is why he didn't invest Guys, he fucked up You always have like passive income I'm just trying to figure out if this is a fit or not You know,
then it's just a matter of picking the right moment A bar Well, propositions late at night in a bar can go Any number of ways.
That's actually...
What's that?
Oh, this is like pure alcohol.
It's not like alcohol.
It is alcohol.
I know because you spit it directly in the water.
Damn, that's so hot, guys.
That's water.
That, see, how it is.
Guys, I have such good risk.
You drink hard liquor from a pint glass?
Actually, I usually just drink it straight from the bottle, but I thought that would be embarrassing.
I'm going to go clean up.
Guys, see?
She likes this.
She likes it.
She likes when I'm lesser than her.
When I'm more pathetic, guys.
Hey, I'm talking to you, bitch.
Yeah, she's into it.
The more pathetic I am, the more...
I'm more attracted to her.
Don't you watch the news?
This is a superhero bar.
Oh, wow.
Are you a superhero?
so cool is this your power pathetic bad people obvious guy well you're really going to ugly you don't remember me wait it's coming back to me hold on yeah it's coming back doctor oh wait sunglasses at night you wear sunglasses indoors at night guy your superpowers they were able to let everyone know in the room that you're a douchebag because you should literally never do that series of poker but even then if you win you're still a loser damn shit bro see i'm not gonna lose sorry i choked on my spit oh mega bitch i can throw yeah no you're flamb and the flame and my skin does not burn i am flamb and you wait oh i do remember you you're that Any villain I busted up.
Wait, he's a villain?
As I literally just said.
I am Flamb.
You can just do that?
You have a criminal record.
I am anymore.
So, you need to get the fuck out of here.
Water.
We can do this the easy way.
There we go.
There, easy way.
No, right?
I've been waiting alone.
I'm not that stupid.
Guys, guys, I know what the fuck alcohol does to fire.
Holy shite.
Yeah, no wonder.
Then you gotta change your job, bro.
What song is that?
Bro, I wanted to live.
Your mouth, it's whistling.
Come on, we should get you to a hospital.
No, Koop.
Fucking guy needs a dentist.
Oh, hey, there's Jack.
Sorry, shy.
Should be able to reattach it.
Punch up.
work that way you're thinking of fingers and dicks you know what give it a shot is it funnier with alcohol do i not live i get it can you just tell blazer i'm outside oh out of here relax i'm leaving
wouldn't alcohol hurt me more like hey i couldn't find you uh it's cool i was just admiring the art on the dumpster can't tell why anyone would put those words together why are you holding drinks nightcap god she's an alcoholic actually according to the bartender that's exactly what you are what happened in there i walk out and the bartender's pissed the whole energy is awkward and i almost rolled the heck out of my ankle on this slippery floor the guy fell down it was pretty funny yeah is so into us she got me free alcohol i fell down usually you're supposed to get her alcohol does that not sound are they both for herself hold these i know a place you're strong it's a little out there easier if we fly whoa oh she's carrying me too damn no she's definitely the top in this relationship oh that's pretty okay that's beautiful Upies!
We got upies!
Yay!
Yeah, she's the muscle, mommy.
This is like LA propaganda.
To sit on it.
Oh, yeah.
That would have been cool.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Phenomenal.
Because you can see it.
And it looks like there's a couple up there already.
I really needed this.
this has been pretty overwhelming you know yeah where's the traffic often and i think i really needed this so thank you for bringing me out i had a really great time don't you worry about it robert robertson how do you know my name that's his name robert robertson okay i'll tell you but you ended up with yeah yeah three times it happened three times grandpa bobby then my dad who i called dad but everyone else called robbie and then me robert robert robertson i wanted to be taken seriously family tradition robbie is the third they did it three times he died in the suit before i was born dad was killed fighting shroud that's when i There was a little inheritance and the life insurance money.
I'm so sorry.
That's smart.
I think as a superhero, you should always take life insurance.
Just your run-of-the-mill sad superhero origin story.
The family tradition, if there is one, is dying in that suit, which I guess I don't have to worry about anymore.
What is it?
I'm not quite drunk enough to share my origin story just yet.
but remember she never said how she knew definitely she'd like doxed him how did she know bro doxing is not a joking matter
yeah we can work with this what kisser let's do it can't i only have two options anyway i gotta get what i gotta take what i can get
I'm You took off my mask and then docks me.
It's my fault.
I'm so sorry.
You didn't I mean you didn't okay That is not true guys.
We all saw she started it about things That is I'm sorry.
How did I fumble?
She baited me Unprofessional I'm not sure.
She literally docks to me I'm actually here on official business how I know your name the proposition i mentioned right before you spit in my mouth still mortified about that and then she got me alcohol do you remember a superhero named track star remember of course he's like family that i haven't talked to in a while but what about him i work with him at sdn he recommended you mentioned that he worked she put her head on my chin what am i supposed to play with that it was kind of my babysitter for a while how's he doing he's doing great he's he's why i'm here Robert I would like to make you an offer in exchange for dispatching and mentoring some of our rookie heroes SDN can make you mecha man again oh wait I get a job nice this is their disposal no more paying out of pocket for repairs support staff the whole this is an interview so this was like some sort of interview I was worried that you might be see unstable damaged unfit i did beat up a reporter on live television but like all
superheroes do that it's a big investment it'll take considerable time and money to get the suit repaired and the missing pieces replaced plenty of time to learn how to dispatch nine to five job let's go oh my god dispatch i know jobs your work common mistake she is just nice thank you champion thank you for Thank you.
Thank you.
What do I say?
No, I have a lot left to give and what if I say no like then I'll hate you forever And I'll push you off this billboard Man, yeah, that's hot and no one would suspect a thing Nope, not a one Wait, so you want me dispatching?
What's that even mean?
Roll credits guys joke you would be the first to be sent to HR God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you drunk people noted Am I waiting or are you waiting?
What's going on?
It was supposed to open up when I threw it to you.
Oh, there it is.
Pop it on.
This is part of the assessment.
I just leave.
I just reject the job.
Title game over.
Greetings and welcome to this training simulation.
We may be superheroes, but we're nothing without SDN's real hero, the dispatcher.
So dispatcher, where do we start?
What if I...
Wait, what if I fail?
Does the game just end?
Well, it appears we've got our first call from a subscriber.
I saw some scary, suspicious men last night leaving the old movie theater.
You'll receive requirements to help you determine which heroes to send yourself against the strength of the devil's fortified.
Okay.
Such an array of brave heroes to choose from.
How could you possibly pick just one?
What the fuck is brain though?
This graph will show you what a hero does well and not so much.
Charisma.
Okay, charisma, combat, intelligent, vigor, mobility, charisma.
Okay.
A hero with a knack for vigor and combat looks right for the job.
That sounds like me.
Phenomoman.
Phenomoman, alright.
Now that at least one hero is being dispatched, it's time to get to work all right a sound approach
i will now return to sdn
when a hero returns to sdn they'll need some much needed rn that stands for rest and relaxation oh it is thor's voice actor we could never escape margaritas everywhere i go don't forget to review your hero's performance it always comes again until you do all right this is my nine to five job now okay how did they do state of the art graph we can see an analysis of what skills the call required okay let's see how well i did after responding to that caller's well call there's no such thing as a perfect fit use your intellect and your roster to your advantage.
Okay, so I just need to make sure I get the best fit possible.
The more that my skills align with the needs of the job, the more likely I am to succeed.
Okay.
That seems easy enough.
Right?
Organized criminals, often led by figurehead supervillains, are the scourge of Southern California.
We work tirelessly to root them out.
all right we've got a potential villain hideout on the college campus on college campus brains not brawn sdn's diverse array of heroes can solve investigate decode a mysterious clue okay it's investigation okay so mobility you're not that smart
intelligent charisma mobility yeah you're not that smart i'm gonna need to send you there all right i think brain book would be the best right I got it There you go Knowledge is power Knowledge is power Yeah she has glasses on
I don't need to send to Oh she did it Yeah see Oh shit Yeah see I did it Oh nice Guys we did it Nice see she didn't die Alright the museum is doing an existence on this local and needs a guest speaker.
Incorporate your unique perspective.
A better city, brick by brick.
Okay, it has to be charisma, man.
Who has... Oh, nope.
I need someone with charisma.
Oh, he can talk.
The sweet talker.
Yeah, it has to be the sweet talker.
Yeah.
I mean, I could get two.
Doesn't really matter, right?
There you go.
Let's grab two.
Two for one.
One of your heroes needs you.
As their leader, your heroes will look to you.
Make choices and follow where they lead.
It's boring.
We're going to have to improvise.
Sprinkle.
Oh, show off your moves.
That's what kids like to see.
That's right.
I assume.
These choices need the right skill.
Remember each of your hero's strengths and weaknesses.
A perfect dispatch.
You are a natural.
Imagine calling superhero.
I am.
I'm like the 9-1-1 Dispatcher.
Oh my god.
That's What's got that?
That's what's got this patch.
Karen, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
And Doki And there's the phone.
Oh my God.
It's like we called 9-1-1 and you get me.
How fucked are you?
The convoy of Diablo's goons are harrying the highway patrol.
Intercept overwhelm.
As if traffic in this city was not bad enough.
Who is?
Speaking of traffic and going places.
Okay.
Does SDN offer paid time off to take vacations?
Of course.
PTO accrues at a regular rate over time.
Wait, there's paid vacation too?
As long as you discuss your schedule with your manager well in advance.
What the fuck is a PTO?
Yeah, what the fuck is a PTO?
Okay, okay, okay.
There's a giant monster attacking.
Oh, shit.
Um, don't worry.
They'll be fine.
I got time.
No, I don't think sending the, okay, um, all right, there you go.
The diabolical supervillain El Diablo is attacking Los Angeles General.
Oh, shit.
It's one of my arch nemesis's.
Oh, he must have been using the convoy ambush as a distraction.
Okay, by the time, I can send one each.
Oh, shit, no, he's a, oh, no.
Speaking of hospitals, did you know SDN offers a robust benefits package?
You want to get gentle too?
Alright, don't worry.
We can wait a little bit.
We'll put what...
Oh my god.
I need help getting to my doctor's appointment.
Make case before she...
Oh wait, that's mobility.
Alright.
Clock this.
Don't worry.
Help this grandma.
Okay.
There we go.
El Diablo, you go in there.
Alright, defend.
Oh gosh.
That vigor is defend.
Okay, wait.
Actually.
Of course.
Um, who, oh, no, okay.
Uh, um, it'll be fine.
I am on the way.
We're being helped.
Send help, please.
The villains, convince the goons.
Okay, sweet talker.
There you go.
You, baby.
Anything.
Oh, damn.
Wow.
Oh, wait, actually.
Man check.
Oh, wait, no.
It has to be.
There you go.
We are, we're so fine.
We're so fine.
They're returning.
SDN values work-life balance when the bell rings your shift will end very soon All right, no, no, no, everything is fine.
Oh, no, oh no, it's okay.
It's okay.
We we can oh, no It's it's okay everything.
Oh, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh my god Sometimes a hero can use their talents to tip the scales rough up and round the moons superheroes after all Okay, there you go
Did we do it?
We saved the children!
The children are safe and sound.
Okay, that's fine.
Did we do it?
I forgot the check marks, guys.
Yay, we did it!
You crossed the road!
Okay, it's okay.
Big and small.
We never ignore the people of the city, particularly the elderly.
Speaking of retirement, quick question.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, no, yes, but there are limitations.
How did you, you got the messages, Kim?
What's the point of your job?
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
We'll just fire him.
Guys, we'll fire him.
Folks, call me justice.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, we made it just in time.
Okay.
On your mark.
five.
See, I told you guys.
El Diablo's goons are running scared.
We're right on the heels of his sidekick, El Diablo.
How is this my fault?
His whole name is Sweet Talker, and somehow he didn't Sweet Talk his way out of it.
Okay, back, survive the defeat and detain.
El Diablo.
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
We have time to wait a little bit, and then we'll send him over.
all right okay it's fine you just need to rest a little bit all right and then i'll send you in and then i'll send you in excellent choice and then there's no way you guys can fuck this up there's three of you it's a we just fire him
He didn't do his job.
Oh, God.
Oh, it's 100%.
Thank God.
Okay.
Nice.
See?
This should be 100% at that point.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
There's no way.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
What can I say?
A lot, actually.
Look, see?
He did it.
Our shift is done now.
It is time for one.
We just had, like, one person.
One or two person only one or two people died I break time with some of the snack offerings and our break room vending machines every 10 seconds someone dies in the world To be seeing a lot more so like goodbye you know and don't forget to be fun.
Just happen to be his time Well, looks like I'm great at this.
So I'm so good be bad for your negotiating position expect a lengthy
Did I drool on you?
What am I?
Some kind of emergency dispatch?
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, babe.
It makes sense, yeah.
Meet me at the SDN offices tomorrow.
That's a date.
I'm not done saving you yet.
Bro, she can fix me.
See, guys, the more pathetic I am, the more she's into me.
She can fix me.
Every 10 seconds, someone dies.
Ira Toki, hold my beer.
Cameron, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he's a fat-ass dog.
Give him some cereal.
I'm gonna make him fatter.
That's right.
The folks at SDN are the best in the business.
I met a nice lady.
The folks who live here have to deal with a lot.
Bro, I live like this.
Bro, you live like...
Bro, I didn't unpack...
Oh, my God, he is me.
This is how he wins.
This is my house.
This is my apartment.
I'm so immersed.
I feel just like him.
Is there any after-credit scene, or do I just continue?
You live like that?
I wish my apartment was that clean.
No, this episode one, it's episodic.
This is why I didn't play the game until all the episodes are released, because I hate episodic format.
I fucking hate the episodic format in general.
Oh yeah, there you go.
Yeah, okay, it's a 50-50.
Yeah, that's very telltale.
Very telltale-like.
Doki-doki.
Yeah, Linky was a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, next.
Do we all kiss?
You would... See, look at that!
I'm the majority!
We all saw it!
Let the goon drop your success rate.
You perform better than 60% of the players?
Nice.
Too fair, I was fucking around, though.
You and 21% of players attacked the reporter.
You... Okay.
Alright.
I aced it, guys.
Look at that.
You and 53% players ace the tutorial.
Bro, I'm, guys, look, I'm the 1%.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
See, look at that.
I did it.
I aced it.
I let two people die and I'd still pass.
I got, I got an A plus.
Obviously those hostages don't matter.
He was going to die anyway.
Not today, but maybe tomorrow.
Don't keep give into the mind control societal thank you super chat thank you thank you i heard there's a character in here that looks like the arcane girl i'm gonna be late for band practice unexpected things happen every day phenomena man we're literally living in a town where there's super villains someone's gonna have to die you can count on sdn to help lift the burdens life throws at us let sdn be your rock so you can rock SDN is not an insurance company and does not cover damages.
She's definitely not making it to ban practice.
Is SDN like a superhero union?
Hmm?
No, just the commercial.
It was weird.
Weird.
Yeah, right.
Oh, so it's like a union.
Oh my god, even superheroes have a union?
It's a... I'm joking.
Oh, it's like a corpo.
Oh, it's like an...
Oh.
I'm a Famama fan, you might say.
Yeah, he's phenomenal.
He seems cool.
Phenomenal even.
And quite the salesman.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, he could sell snowballs to an Eskimo.
Is it not cool to say?
Snowman.
He could sell snowballs to a snow...
Oh my God, I'm Corpo.
Carson.
Anyone made a snow?
Any color snow doesn't have to be white.
God.
Yeah.
Oh, so it's like a private security firm.
Oh, wait, that's fucked.
If I have to, like, hire someone to save me.
Yeah, just, yeah.
Okay, let me.
Wait, how do they get paid?
Do, like, the civilians they save?
Pay them?
I have so many questions.
No, I mean, yes.
But yes is more.
My powers make everything wet.
Wait, okay.
Okay, I need a no.
Wait, they have to say it's a subscription phase.
guys if you subscribe every month it's like it's a monthly subscription guys if you guys don't want to fucking die make sure to monthly subscribe to the superhero perk that is fuck wait that is I was clearly not paying too much no I'm so confused I was like subscribers like I was like what do you mean subscribers so it's actually a private security firm dude is there any superheroes that do it's like a public defendant you know how like criminals they are they have the right for a lawyer are there superheroes that like you know do it for charity it's like public superheroes you know like you might have to wait like two to three this like five to ten business days oh that's what mecca no wonder i was broke how they call me but yes i am sure it was okay that makes sense now
Oh, there's Flamb.
That's crazy.
A subscription?
Bro, it's like, you're like dangling off the bridge and you're like, sorry, you forgot to pay for your subscription fee.
You missed your payment.
You're Mecca man.
I, you're dead, I thought.
Just on the inside.
You look small or different in person.
Never me your heroes, kid.
Oh, wasn't sure you'd show up.
It's like health insurance.
with extra steps.
Sorry, but I need him for something.
Follow me.
In Doki's world, Batman would fund Wayne Tech by charging $5 a month in protection fee.
I actually gave it a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, that's why the hostage is sad.
What's happening right now?
We don't want too many people knowing them.
We missed the subscription payment.
Heroes, but it's better if you keep your identity a secret.
We've had incidents in the past.
Here.
I remembered you being bigger I was a little drunk Listen, it's gonna be great.
I've never felt silly wearing this Until now.
Yeah, I was trying to imply that with the silence.
It worked get dressed.
I also think superhero costumes are pretty silly Whoa, why is she watching?
Whoa First you want you there's your hallway is this a yeah is this an hr violation this might be the fastest hr violation of a new employee in history yeah whoa yeah turn around we didn't kiss oh it doesn't look like it but i am flexing every muscle in my body right now that's looking right currently no kiss no looking no peeking i i want to say again i'm sorry about last night i regret the way i conducted myself it was a mistake a complicated mistake i can uh go into the details of those complications with didn't it feel like a mistake oh well that makes one of us oh you can turn around now if you want oh you can turn around if you want to strip down in front of you
i've lost scars oh what the guys i have i gotta told you i have so much riz oh there she is our king so uh you two fuck or what we kissed but it was very innocent like cheek innocent or tip of your dick innocent okay oh damn first of all we did not kiss you kissed me second of all it's none of your freaking business whoa she cussed been a good one Robert this is Invisigal she is part of the Phoenix program we take former super villains such as herself and rehabilitate them to re-enter society to use their powers for are those my earrings well they look better on me Invisigal this is Robert he'll be your team's dispatcher oh washed-up dad bought superhero with no superpowers can't wait his identity all of this oh I have a six pack you see it he's still Mac a man but that can't get out and if it does.
I'll know who it came from.
You think I want to tell people our dispatcher's a fucking loser?
If I make superpowers, doesn't automatically make you a superhero.
That's right.
If you're born with one, you have to earn the other.
Well, I'm wet.
I see why you like him.
Look at that trip.
What does that look?
Best by fight club?
Bro, you have asthma.
That ain't fucking, uh, that ain't fucking tough, bro.
It's not tough.
when you have asthma.
And she's at the bottom.
She called herself Invisibitch when she was a villain.
Bro, she looked down.
You saw that.
Yeah, I thought Invisigal felt kind of corny for her.
You saw her look down.
Her eyes flick down.
Just get your shirt on, Dadbot.
I have a six-pack.
It reminds me of the Incredibles.
But we've got what makes the real difference.
Great people.
Even people, and they're still great.
Oh my god, this is depressing.
Facts, scan does literally everything.
This is so depressing.
One of the 3Ds.
This is an actual nine to five officeware.
3Ds?
Dispatching.
Documentation.
Diversity is the third.
Not in terms of priority, of course.
Yep.
We're all about diversity.
Lana works in the mailroom from a different galaxy altogether and then there's Galen way back there born with superhearing.
He's from Florida Florida Bro
Guys She might be a little At work I tend to get a little corny corporate dick meet me in the records room when you're done if you get lost look for the door that says records room guys i think she has a lot of hr violations
anyway thank you for the super chat thank you thank you solely average wise everyone calling him small um i would like to say above average what the bro i almost went in my pants hey you this robber people talking about what's up brother my auntie named me roy but people call me roy bro fist bro what's up bro good to meet you bro likewise the bro code bro he designed bro like like steroid huh they don't know about i know no no no no listen listen it's all natural so i think it's like you know we go scrap we go ground i bust you up and then you know you got saying bro that's that's what i that's what i think he's so peeing holy shit hey you think that's why they call me roy like i'm on steroids but they think i'm some kind of a juice head they think i'm not natty no i'm just kidding i think roy's not natty no i'm just kidding man just making jokes about your name and the shitter it's all right bro it's not too deep i don't care
What is that?
Nice meeting you, Royd.
Even if it was while we were both holding our dates.
You one funny bugger.
Mecca man.
What?
How did you know?
What the fuck?
Okay, so I was worried about your unwashed hand, but now I'm worried that everyone here knows who I am.
Nah, brother.
It's Kapoo.
Need to know basis and Roy need to know.
I don't want to come pick up your soup or fix them for the SDN.
Cool.
You're going to wash before you do that?
Bro, why is everyone doxing me?
Just touch my pants with underwear only.
Even for shake, I just do like this.
Can you show me again?
I don't think I got it.
Oh, you fixed our suit.
Holy shit.
Who's this freckled face, Fung?
How are you?
That's an aggressive way to greet someone.
Look at this skinny latte prick.
Your bones, kid.
you here to whip these assholes in the shape of what that's the idea do i know you um i'm sorry do i know you why are you all tense what it's a hug not a hand job like we're already reminded of that moana guy i'm still confused oh right because i'm old as how about this this jog your memory track star holy i thought he was jabbing why are you accepting hugs from old men you don't know oh and hey they call me chase around yeah it reminds me of mallee yeah sure right yeah chase it's been what 10 15 years has it really been that long yeah i reached out to this little piss ant when his dad passed then he got the duck in me like he owed me money i was in a weird place i understand kid it was tough on all of us so i can't imagine what you went through yeah so what's up you need to tell me why you look like black hindstein sorry i never noticed bucker it's the powers i can move 50 times faster than the average person but i didn't realize until it was too late and i was aging 50 times faster
when i used my powers what that's crazy slower than frozen pissed so how old are you yeah then how old are you really i turned 39 a few months ago he's 39 so i guess this means you're the one person i can't complain to about losing my suit you better not i would resurrect then re-kill your father in front of you if it meant i thought like he was friends with his dad jesus The average 39 year old.
Obviously I'd let Robert have one last.
I love you before I extinguish the light from his eyes.
Was he always like this?
Yes, actually.
We joke, we laugh, we suppress our trauma.
Alright, enough of this feeling shit.
Let's introduce you to your team of losers.
Our team of losers?
Now if I'm being honest, I thought and still think we should have canned these tuners months ago.
wish because if we don't see improvements soon the whole program will be scrapped cool zipped here no pressure oh man bad was a harvard graduate who who will not shut the up about being a harvard graduate oh my god i gotta get him in also orchestrated some of the most effective silicon which are high intention addictive variety of embezzlement wait he's a villain that would eat you ass first after he emptied your penchant wings embezzlement extortion drug possession money laundering for cyber bullying we gotta get him in okay controls the fire and the flame and his skin does not burn right you've met him didn't you ever run in with him years back we need that we need a cyber bully
none of these are as important who you met i'm mad at that situation crazy program on a condition we didn't ask questions that's a little suspicious now suspicious really of a criminal that turns invisible and doesn't like to answer questions what tipped you off sherlock i feel like loner thief loner i feel like wait what is his oh bad boy con man that's your villain name that's such a stupid ass okay oh wait no okay never mind i thought aka invisible because it was like okay never mind never mind this is just an app extra i was like why would if your villain name is bat boy con man that is a shitty ass villain name here we have coupe which i recently learned is a french ballet term that means two cut hence the knives i thought it was cool so everybody calls it coop she was an assassin for the mob then went independent aggravated assault extortion first degree murder kidnapping stalking jesus true kill count like many things about her is unknown oh nobody knows oh but like wait she's
bad at fighting but she all fucking she's a killer how do you be bad at fighting can't kill carnival strong man who made a deal with a sorceress she gave him the strength of 10 men his muscles grew but his body shrunk he's got all the charming brains of a greasy bowling ball battery parole violation public intoxication second degree murder only second degree god you're such a shitty villain um pain immunity all right There he is.
They're shy.
Malabala.
Oh.
I heard you can't romance her.
So what's the point?
Oh.
That's magic.
Wait, that's fucking magic.
Oh my god.
We can't escape Marvel rivals.
Murder is still murder.
Yeah, you can't romance her apparently.
Sonars and they sponsor atheist true crime.
Assault, burglary, forgery, kid happy.
degree guys come on do better that's golem he is a construct a construct yeah a bunch of dirt and mud made sentient with magic oh it's clay face i think he's lonely is clay face plus uh what's his name solomon grundy large mass of clay and dirt enjoys poetry and basketball difficulty with squeezing through oh there she is but you plan forever wait how is she a villain and a pop star Why is she dressed like a pop star?
Oh, because she's taxed.
She's actually super talented.
Oh my god, wait.
Assault, drug possession, DUI, tax evasion.
I guess for how you can't be a super villain if your fucking super villain thing is tax evasion.
Music snap, highlight consistently requests a return to her trailer.
Holographic.
How is she the super villain?
If all she does was just evade taxes.
Like everyone does it.
Not me, not me, not me.
It's true.
You're not me, though.
Not...
Papa Smirked you're all reformed just like you.
Thank you, but a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Z team, my team, their in- Get a Doki, drugs are bad.
You're all not the true of dangerous fuck-ups.
We're not looking for miracles.
But we'd love one if we could get it.
Can you show him his desk?
Sure.
It's not so super.
if you're if you only crime is like drugs and tax evasion how is that the super part it's just a regular the one percent pretty sparse but feel free to decorate
they're just being the one percent that's not really quite super villain of them this computer's older than you look wait so we're doing this i haven't even met the team only one of them yeah them fucking committed murder what the fuck we like to start slow that's weak as hell don't make it past the first dispatch and this is better for everybody's safety what do you mean safety you'll be fine and this here is our little slice of the south land whenever there's a crisis in the area we get a call and guess who i'm the dispatch my team are the fucking now put your headset on and introduce yourself to these pricks what they gave me the worst people to manage
Sorry, my first shift.
Tell me that's not your real first day.
You can't be this sugar the other day.
Rafi.
Can we clear the channel, please?
There's a lot of overlapping on this.
Bro, I got the suicide squad.
I got the worst fucking villains for this shit.
He packing money.
Ah!
But he's got a lot of bruises.
Which I'm into.
Again, please clear the channel.
Clear comes.
People are dying.
Clear comms.
These calls are fucking recorded for training fucking purposes.
So keep the fucking line clear before we send your stupid fucking asses back to whatever fucking cell we pulled your stupid fucking asses out of.
Damn.
Jeez.
My son's balloon is stuck in a tree.
Can you send someone?
Alright, climb a 40 feet tree to retrieve a don't make the child cry.
Okay.
Obviously, someone with charisma, right?
Oh, yes, sir.
Charisma, mobility.
Okay, you can climb.
No, okay, I would assume climbing is what I'm looking for.
I have, no, she's, she'll make someone cry.
Uh-huh.
Oh, my God.
No, he's gonna make, bro, when the child sees this, it's gonna cry.
He doesn't need to do anything.
What's your problem?
Are you sure?
I feel like, I feel like he's just gonna cry.
Okay, what have we said?
like someone who can have hot god they all have shitty mobility okay okay he can fly guys i don't think he can fly okay we're gonna you know all right we'll try we'll try i think he's gonna yeah no i will not try okay i feel like hmm big mistake huge all right maybe flamb because he has fly and a little bit of charisma he has more charisma than invisible bitch and it's not the me Mr. Vanderstank is requesting a hero for a very important event.
Who's this Vanderstank guy?
Willem Vanderstank.
Certified genius.
Literally, he has a certificate.
It's okay.
You aren't a genius if you need a piece of paper that says you're a genius?
Very high profile.
Send someone that will make...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Who would...
Oh, she'll make it.
She'll make us look good.
She's a celebrity.
No, she's a celebrity, guys.
There's no way.
Why would I send Charlie?
Sonar?
Okay, we'll send sonar.
Right, yes.
Are you sure?
I feel like Prism will have the...
He is smart.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
You're right.
He is.
Okay.
Did I mention I went to Harvard?
I hope he doesn't burn the tree down.
I'll take Wednesday.
Tuesday.
Guys, do you think I'm concerned?
We're taking bets on when you'll quit.
Okay, we're gonna see if he burns the tree.
Today's Friday.
Okay.
Oh, my God, it was...
Oh, my God, we did it.
He didn't burn the tree down.
Holy fuck.
Okay, 100% I told you guys.
You're on fire today.
After Flamate Games plus one dis-effect.
Guys, look at that.
He didn't burn the tree down.
We're fine.
I'm so good at this.
What's this?
Oh, my God.
A pipe is dark.
What?
Oh.
Okay, I guess I fix...
I hack now.
Okay, I was Okay, alright I guess I also help Utilities too Let's see if I can do this Got you Alright Where the fuck am I doing this
Okay, but what Why am I fixing this?
I'm also a plumber Like, did they buy this Off of S&D Tech?
I can up a day apparently so i guess subscribers also get free uh free mechanics too
all right what's this out of my bar before they destroy it and don't set the two heroes are fighting each other break up the bra diplomatically is possible okay okay that little shit maybe uh prison uh you did though you're gonna sign prison duplicates the hero to That placing dirt.
Oh!
Wait, that's cool.
So we're going to shut up about it.
She can blot on them.
We needed another backup dancer.
All right.
I feel like that's diplomatically.
All right, let's go.
As fast as these legs will let me.
What's this?
We're going to sign?
Oh, okay.
So it just reads their information.
All right.
I am progress at the yacht club.
Pursue to return the boat in one piece.
Okay.
do it you're fine there's a difference between a you're fast as well all right let me show you 100 let's go look at that easy i told you guys see good job sonar going on with sonar oh oh sonar transforms his intelligent swaps with combat and his charisma swaps with vigor until the next time working on controlling it oh that's fine i mean as you read on this mecca man people are people like it drinking alone a robot guy these idiots are fighting over the name fight man let's try giving maybe you hear that flamb you got your ass kicked by gives them the idle makeover shut the fuck up okay fight man okay so one of them wants to be fight man and then okay let's give you them an idle makeover maybe maybe that's what they need give them a makeover yeah all right from who have been reborn as Sabre and the Bruiser.
Oh, nice.
See, look at that.
I mean, that's hardcore.
That sounds hardcore as fuck.
Flambe, you're off route.
Wait, where are you going?
Flambe, where the fuck are you going?
Hey, someone's robbing the museum.
I don't know what you do, man.
I just started today.
Avoid motion sensors and apprehend.
Oh, God, I don't have...
Oh, wait, there you go.
Sure thing.
Security has been taken over.
Avoid.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, maybe I'll send...
You know what?
Fuck it.
You guys work together.
You guys got this.
You guys don't need charisma.
We just need to be invisible.
Do we need two?
I'll send two, just in case.
Security here is amateur hour.
Oh.
Fire at a local park has gotten out of control.
Did you start that fire?
Oh.
The fire that's burning two blocks from where you're standing.
and start that okay let's fire can be fixed later stop walking around i've got enough problems without you making oh it's 63 whatever man is that it no how oh it's okay there's no one alive on the boat anyway it's fine jenny the bone zone ds here today's topic is all about sdn hiring criminals
Shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we'll wait for him to come back.
Um, maybe.
He can throw clay at it.
Oh, shit.
Hack.
We're gonna hack the system.
I got you guys.
I got my PC, my wooden keyboard.
I can hack this.
As long as I'm not timed, I'm timed.
I had one criteria.
I'm timed.
Who would have thought?
Okay.
We're so done.
Oh.
Oh, if I mess up one, I didn't even realize that.
There you go.
We did it.
No pressure.
at all we found it too many soft skills hey a hero ranked up good oh did he what did he do every rank up earns skill oh using per increasing stats what do we want anyway uh let's have more you could be more more smart actually what do we want do we want charisma or mobility intelligent all right let's do it We'll make him smarter.
mad bat.
Only sonar level is up.
Everybody should step back.
We've encountered these thieves before.
Track down no members to find their hideout.
I feel like intelligent... I can wait a little bit.
I just need...
Okay, here we go.
It's time to educate them.
He said I got arrested for tax evasion.
I wish.
Okay, what do...
Okay, we've counted these thieves before.
Compile and cross-reference past case.
Going now.
Track down members to find their hideout.
Maybe?
Yeah, okay.
Well, we have to track them down, wouldn't you?
Maybe these two?
Ag and...
Tata.
Ag and mobility.
I feel like you need intelligence, but none of them are smart in my career.
This is a little bit this bad.
I don't have any smart people in my crew.
All right, we can wait a little bit Disrupted use your body Just use your body.
You're made of clay.
You're fine
Oh, thank god.
Okay, that's good.
We contained it
All right Okay, there we go need someone smart which is none of them that's fine we'll send these to damn dude how'd you get an ass like that hello squads girl oh i was afraid you'd say we're doing so good guys look at that we can reform the villains all right do you educate them i swear to god okay 89 that's good don't be intimidated job charlie business half man half bat all freak all right this should be fine this was not fine oh yeah it was fine oh thank god okay it is fine okay keep forgetting yellow is us or what yellow is is us hey bobby here william vanders think needs a security detail uh i'm willing to pitch him some stuff i've been working on ability to pretty sure that's exactly what he's trying to avoid and then charisma let's go You can only choose one solution.
Send Sonar.
Send literally anyone else.
Sure.
Send Sonar.
A high-ranking Vanderstanker.
It would mean a lot.
Let Sonar meet his hero.
William and pitch him ideas.
The other option will disappear.
Alright.
Oh, I can wait.
It's okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh, shit.
Okay, what's this?
That little shit I want in behind bars.
Track down and encourage him to turn his life around.
Gosh, okay.
Oh, we'll think about it.
All right, it's okay.
He's resting.
All right, there you go.
I don't know if you should meet his hero while he's a...
You know what?
Fuck it.
Never meet your heroes.
Go ahead.
You will not regret this.
Never meet your heroes.
I didn't think I would until you said that.
All right.
He's got to learn.
Guys, he's got to learn to never meet his heroes.
Jerry L.B.
Go for it.
Guys, he's a Harvard graduate.
He's going to learn today.
Self and use and will be key.
Okay, it's well guarded.
Oh.
Okay, we'll send these two.
We'll send them both together.
how long was the last dispatcher here two days two days yeah no how the fuck did that happen oh the nerves and he's second guessing his human meat alternative how's make it relate just wait oh god um um oh fuck i don't know i don't know if he is relatable guys he's a harvard graduate it's really hard to make it relatable uh
should he wing it or make wing it he's not he's not really oh just tell a story oh god uh oh man this feels like a fail wing it we fall i feel like winging it would be like charisma and we don't really have any of that right now story is bad guys which one is it okay because he wing it because he's a bat
I don't know sonar just uh, you know, just wing it.
Well, that seems I feel like that's correct.
Oh, wait Oh, oh You know wing it fly, maybe a stretch, but you know, come on don't turn into a monster.
Oh Yeah, oh, I told you guys some fuckers out never meet your heroes guys I told you never meet your heroes
the art.
I feel like capture the thieves?
Maybe?
Get the paintings out.
Oh, get the paintings out quietly.
We have her.
Get the paintings out quietly.
I'm a screamer.
Yeah, there you go.
I was gonna say I have her.
Custom option.
Oh, scare the kids straight.
That's right.
Scared the kids straight.
Tell her she's gonna go to hell if he keeps going.
Scaring children.
Obviously my favorite part of the job.
That's fucking right.
scared shitness was it scared straight tell the kid he'll go to hell all right nice what the fuck grannies i got this hold up aren't you banned yeah and i gotta get unbanned wait do we put her in yeah nice try dude i'm not going anywhere oh shit oh i have to put her in okay no i'm not going for or sent reduces travel time and call completion time okay he just really likes grannies i guess anything i could level up no okay can i get ice down here please what does that mean what ask before tapping we got access to security cams of sd and subscribers all over our territory wow really is that legal don't ask questions just always make sure to read the fine print didn't know you were a fellow monster but she's thinking of a super thank you thank you oh shit what's going on hello right i feel like you've said that a lot in your life what happened that'll happen this is how i found the place the old guy who i assume is granny was laying here that's granny look can you just focus what you got
adhd or something yes is it that obvious yes it is well then answer the question i want to sit here and fixate on it see the long cream ones uh long ones with the cream inside the clairs um oh they're called oh oh it's french yep you got me i love gobbling on hot sloppy guys guys no i just i like it clairs guys guys first day they're french all your funny funny jokes they're french guys
What are you doing?
You're going to poke it with a stick?
Check his pulse.
Granny's alive.
Thank Christ.
I don't want to have to lift this guy.
So, can I go now?
No, this isn't a wellness check.
It's a B&E.
Let's figure out if the PURP is still there.
PURP?
B&E?
Okay, Lieutenant.
Fuck, I can't think of a character from a cop show.
Cool.
Well, why don't you stay put and work on that while I get another camera up online?
She's my least favorite.
the worst of the lot that surprises me you guys got similar energy how do i switch cameras don't put your ass to think it was protecting thank you we're getting tech advice from an old person bro i'm not even oh he's 39.
you're hearing bro from an old person dan lieutenant dan is that is that a thing yes i am the legless vietnam vet from forest gump sick burn access to nine what am i doing something wrong pushing that button just says access denied Damn it.
Sometimes people add extra security.
They don't understand it just makes it harder for us to do our job.
Oh, God.
Am I hacking?
Bro, it's a donut shop.
What kind of security do you need in a donut shop?
Clearly not a really good donut shop if there's no one there.
Bro, there's no one even in this donut shop.
Oh, my God.
It's money laundering, isn't it?
Oh, God.
He's money laundering here, isn't he?
Why does a donut shop even need extra security?
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying!
There's nobody even eating here!
What?
What the fuck?
How do I do this?
That's odd.
Oh, the key?
Oh!
I thought it was one of those like Guess things where like if you get a thing Right?
Okay Up down left left Okay up down up down left I thought it was what it's like it's like wordo I thought it was wordo God the dude thought it was a riddle It would have been smart if it was wordo We got here Hey shut up for a sec You're not alone Oh What's this?
He's coming your way, armed.
You need to disappear.
Why are you whispering, you idiot?
You're in my ear.
Is this shroud?
Oh, shit.
It's defense this now.
Oh, wait, he asked his other thing.
It's just a gusher.
Be careful.
Lieutenant Dan.
Never mind.
Me, that's like a name, but I'm cheating.
Got any more great advice?
Oh, shit.
No, it's her deep up asthma.
Go invisible!
I was too busy I was watching to cut teeth.
Shit.
But I want a donut too.
Oh shit!
Invisigo, just hold him off while he find a way to help.
Oh, am I hacking?
I can use the overhead sprinklers to short out his blaster.
Oh shit, oh I'm timed.
Okay, I was gonna say as long as I'm not timed, it'll be fine.
Got him.
Okay.
Up down.
Oh?
Oh, shit.
Um, up down.
Okay, what's this?
Uh, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, yeah!
Wait, why am I doing that?
I should be using you guys.
What?
Nice.
Water badge.
I should have using ad chat.
Oh, fuck.
No, my asthma.
Okay.
who's that who came in phenomenal oh granny i don't think you know how to use that thing so why don't you shut the fuck up oh i'm one of the good guys you yeah right don't fuck with me okay nobody fucks granny oh shit great advice lieutenant dan you're not calling lieutenant dan take out the thief granny doesn't work and you sound dumb granny doesn't even know how to shoot that thing He's the only one with this finger on a trigger.
You know what?
It's my life on the line.
I'm done listening to you.
The thing's gonna blow that man's arm off and there's a whole building with me in it.
Fuck off.
I'm disarming the device.
No, Invisig out?
That's a direct order.
Wait, she doesn't even care?
What?
I...
She didn't even listen to me!
Bro!
Oh, fuck.
Fuck!
Invisigah, you there?
Oh, shit, that's his dick.
Oh, his ass?
She's gone rogue!
I think he must have had something else to do because he left.
Oh wait, does he have life insurance?
Oh, he's alive?
You think he'll still be subscribed?
Guys, do you think he'll cancel his subscription, guys?
Sometimes people, you know, get electrical burns.
She disobeyed a direct order.
the problem this isn't the army and these ain't soldiers guys he won't he's not gonna unsubscribe right maybe if we send him one free month take a breather we can one free month he'll stay on here it's okay guys we'll give him a voucher and if you're sorry you got shot are you sure you're not actually 80 years old sorry you guys shot here's one month free
what Two failures?
It wasn't even my fault.
Bro, one of the failures wasn't even my fault.
Take a hero out of resting.
About random point.
Oh, nice.
Here's one hero to receive the combat skill upgrade.
Oh.
Do I want to be stronger?
Alright, you guys.
You guys.
I chat.
Well, I'll let you guys pick.
You know what?
I'll let you guys pick.
Punch up.
Punch up?
Alright.
I'll give Punch up his little combat.
Yeah.
I'll let you guys customize my team.
We do it together.
We're a team.
Oh, hey, Twinkie.
Oh, yeah, they're back.
Oh!
Oh, gross.
What kind of superhero flinches?
I'm just a dispatcher.
If you had people trying to kill you for the last 15 years, you'd be jumpy too.
What makes you think my life has been any different?
You think growing up surrounded by a bunch of shipbag villains I didn't need to watch my back?
I can't just disappear.
Yeah, I actually have to face my problems.
What the fuck?
You can't just go around.
Why is he keep screaming?
His name's Sonar.
is he blind what's up what are you asking why are you explaining your um you know what never mind good shift this guy is weird yeah he is look i actually just came by to celebrate the mission going well didn't mean to interrupt your little snack what do you need to preach you like a little baby bird bitch you ignored my order direct order how can you exactly soldier trash the place the suspect got away you got the client hurt you think when that guy signed up for sd and the in the back of his ball sack getting scorched because they don't mention that in the commercials.
First of all, the place was trashed when I got there.
Second, I'm sure Granny would take some crispy nuts over losing his arm.
As far as the bad guy, fuck shit happens.
The fact of the matter is that shit didn't need to happen.
Yeah, because what the fuck was he saying?
It doesn't get fried and we get the perp if you had just fucking listened to me.
You ask for help, then I can...
What?
What's he doing?
What the fuck is he grinding, Coffee?
I make the calls, not you.
advice you're right at home behind that desk because you're no hero you were a nerd playing a video game and a suit your daddy built now you're a twitchy little bitch turtle without its show but she knows who i am too a real hero can't just press a button make their problem you need me the fact of the matter is you need me way more that's right based on what i saw today you wouldn't last a day as mecha man because there isn't a mech suit in the universe that will keep you from being a selfish oh yeah she was in that room i already forgot about her she's so invisible yes you think i'm in i think she likes that when i talk back to her whoa good you think i'm in
you're gonna eat those twinks that's not what they're you know what And I can't romance him?
What the fuck?
What happened to your nose?
Here we go.
You have a tissue hanging from your nose, Robert.
I was trying to ignore it.
Invisi, yeah, so I'm going to snitch.
I'm snitching.
Invisi got punched me in the face.
But I asked for it.
Robert, this is serious.
Bro, this game is so good.
I'm clearly got here playing it.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
I literally asked for it.
I've been enjoying the series so far.
I...
He eats swings and I can't romance him exactly.
Let's go with that.
I'm a fucking nerd.
I'm here to assist Robert's first shift.
And aside from whatever happened here, I thought it was...
She punched me!
I'm reporting to HR.
I was watching on the monitor.
The work you did dispatching.
I don't think the Z team has ever had a better shift than that.
We just might need to confront the fact that it might be the best they can do.
Especially the way the Granny Penguin.
Oh yeah, the Z team.
ideal but I've seen so much worse with invisible let's be real she ain't gonna make it she's difficult to work with sure but I see a lot of promise in her really even the other Z-teamers respect her they're afraid of her I should have done better maybe a couple wires got crossed toward the end there I could have been guys what do you mean the romance option is God I'm gonna save it okay I'll save it cost them for you I'm gonna save it you should be proud the bar is very low with this group well it's not low for me look i like to make a joke and keep things light as much as the next person but when it comes to where i could turn it around here if you want the phoenix program to survive the bar needs to go up and how would we do that by treating the z team like what they are a bunch of villains and leading a supervillain team takes a different approach than a superhero team i need to be around them i need them to see i'm all in and they love the only kind i know and based on what i've
seen the only version they'll respond to i'm not saying everyone will make it they won't i'm not saying it won't get spicy it will but when it does i also need you to trust me to handle it i don't want you stepping in they need to respect me even if i don't have powers okay we'll do it your way monday we'll get them in a room and introduce them to their new super villain leader i can't promise at work i can only promise that i'll do my best what if i like poached them and start my own company way more fun to watch but then it's for like super villains only so it's like people have to subscribe to us to make sure we don't kill them i feel like that's more money hey kid what i think what are you doing yeah no no no no i get it did this it's so it's weird because yeah i saw So it's a mob.
Yeah, and they don't want to unsubscribe.
The moment they unsubscribe, they're dead.
So people who aren't subscribed, they get killed.
And we get more customers because people don't want to die.
See, I'm SDN's newest.
The moment they unsubscribe, it's fucking over.
boy okay cool so it's my pleases pleasure and it's a business model it's not a crime we get so thank thank you thank you so much happy to help that's it's Friday I'm not gonna ask you headed out oh yeah great thanks kid welcome to the team water boy yeah welcome to you you too what even is his powers like Does he just...
Oh, God!
Oh, oh, fuck!
Guys, I know what his powers are.
All right.
I mean, I'm not contingent on you as a busy team.
I want to do that to you.
It's good to know.
But don't worry about that.
I'm just...
I mean, shouldn't have ass.
I shouldn't.
No, do you want to grab dinner?
Hey, so do you want to grab dinner or something?
Like, as like platonic, you know, platonic friends, you know?
There's something I've been meaning to tell you.
It's a little awkward to mention, but since the other night, I...
Blonde Blazer.
Hey.
Oh, it's that guy.
He's...
He was in the commercial that we saw.
What?
Who is this?
I thought I'd catalogued all of your work companions.
You hoi!
Oh my god, it's so proud of music.
Oh my god, Bowser Jr. Robertson, leader of the Phoenixes.
Blonde Blazer told me about you.
Did she say, I don't know, what came up in that talk?
She said you're a capable, honorable man that truly cares for others.
Why are you so small?
Hey, come on.
You gotta stop asking people.
Oh, it's above average.
It's not about the size.
It's the flow.
It's all about how you use it.
It's the flow of the ocean.
Was his lack of size and strength an issue?
No, he was great.
it was great it was a great first day that is phenomenal we should celebrate blonde blazer and i have reservations in tokyo at a restaurant where the owner dreams of sushi you should join us you know what i think i will you know what i will that's right i will blonde blazer that's fucking right I don't know if we can add one more to the that's tricky right I'm gonna sit in that chair Us to get there in time we'd have to hit supersonic speed and Robert here Oh,
would he die?
Yeah, I think he would die.
Oh, no Perhaps another time.
Yeah, for sure That's fucking right.
What do you mean?
What the fuck?
Why did you not tell me you were dating him?
He flies a little faster She's just like two days ago.
A pleasure.
Now, could you step back?
The power of my life.
She has no right to say what the fuck.
Phenomenal.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, he flies a lot faster.
There's no such thing as it's complicated.
Just be like, I'm dating someone.
What the fuck do you mean?
She said it's complicated.
You know what she could have said?
Sorry.
I didn't mean it, but.
Flare with you.
I have a boyfriend.
That's all you have to say.
Yeah, uncomplicated.
You know what's that saying?
What you can say other than it's complicated?
I have a boyfriend.
You could have just said that.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say bro, who are the people damn bro because that's fucked?
Think that phenomenal small being that you I said thank you was super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I ratted Me a 24% ratted her out You and you and 26% attempted to ask to blaze her out you and 10 Said yes to the donor
You're 7% right now guys all I'm saying is It's that It's that I had to Okay I had to I had to like Rub it in You and Twit left sonar meet And it went terrible Never beat your ears I didn't do the saber in the bruise That's the name is fucking fire though That is a fire name Your most hero with sonar you perform better see i perform better in 50 of theirs i got 50 50.
uh love the malta as long as i'm not timed i'll be fine dokey's singing this game in full of quick time events and time risk never changed donkeys bye look
all i'm saying i just never meet your heroes i was teaching sonar a lesson i want to grab some food wait let me microwave some food real quick all right i'll be right back guys i want to microwave some food real quick.
Also, grab some water.
I know!
I am back.
I got food.
Sorry, it took me a while.
I had to reheat my food.
Alright, there we go.
I'm ready.
Thank God I can watch stuff, too.
Smokey, Mike, Pato, Matt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had, like, a teriyaki beef and shrimp rice.
That didn't finish.
So, I can...
Yesterday.
So, I'm gonna...
Finish shit today.
Fuck up.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hey, what are you doing?
Brother.
You're warranty.
Are ready, boy.
I don't know about finishing this game today.
We'll see.
We'll see you in chapter four.
No worries.
I'm pretty strong.
That's not what I'm saying.
How you got this thing inside your apartment anyways?
Oh, super heavy, the bugger.
I disassembled it and took it in little pieces, which is what I thought you'd be doing.
And how long does that take you?
no it was four days i get 20 minutes that's true it just feels like you could be a little gentler with it it is you know my whole fucking life every time i walk in this place i get sad that don't happen to you no one ever told you i'm poor i'm poor why do you think i take this job here does that make you feel good subscribers you're not poor if you can keep this suit going like uh where you sleep uh the chair figuring that out you're figuring that out huh so even the beef got a bed this is the type of apartment you see when the detective kicked the door in you know shine the flashlight serial killer all right i get it can we focus on where the astropos at lost in the blast while i was flying no clue where it landed bro this is like i spent a couple weeks after it happened trying to track it down it powered a whole suit yes the only piece of the suit my dad didn't have schematics for.
Is that going to be a problem?
Ah, mine now.
That's really how I live, too.
How'd you know about the Astral Pulse?
It's actually two wicked pieces of tech, huh?
First you get the Astral Pulse, this genius design energy cell.
But inside them, you get the stellar core.
Can I help?
No, brother.
You good.
What's crazy is when you mix the control fusion reactions with the plasma containment.
Oh, brother.
You got a core?
one super crazy energized plasma state unreal stuff like you caught one small star and chop him in a bottle genius oh this sounds pretty fucking important you said we're good actual paul super awesome but uh we'll be all right
maybe we go for a lot of medals this time huh you know i actually met your dad one time long time ago first time i come mainland He'll catch me trying for steal stuff from radio shack.
Then we talk tech stuff for like an whole hour Then he would take me jail That's how I ended up in a Phoenix program.
Oh, he was a villain conversation.
I ever had with him Yes,
when you're building astropulses, there's not much time.
Oh, yeah, he has big daddy issues not so sure about that I don't understand you see there's gear heads then there's science nerds one kind garage the other kind You know your father on good gear head, but I just can't see how he'll make something like the pulse You know science nerd how would you know this from talking to him?
Maybe he used to work with Shroud because I'm both True, I'm the one gonna fix your suit.
Oh My god, what if Shroud was the one that made him the thing?
That one over there that's your father's suit We gonna make this one the robber's suit the robber?
garbage, dude.
This is incredible, Royd.
Oh, you're so bad.
Royd, I don't know what to say.
Thank you.
Thank you is what I need to say.
This is unreal.
We make the man mecha again.
Oh my god, I'm gonna have a job again.
Or like, I guess technically it wasn't my job.
I was doing it for free.
My phone!
Watch where you're going, bro!
Hey!
Yeah.
Watch where you're going.
I think you did that on purpose.
That's right.
I fend for myself.
I'm not gonna let him walk over me just because he's made a play.
I'm his manager.
What is rude?
He bumped into me!
Hey, Chase.
I need a favor.
How am I the rude man?
It's not enough of a favor getting you this job working with those stupid ass pieces of...
Oh, who's this, huh?
Who's this little guy?
His name's Beef and he's the favor.
You mind keeping an eye out?
I feel bad leaving him at home, but I don't want anything happening to him.
Robert, I would literally let everyone here melt in eternal hell including you.
He's like Toby.
I'm sorry.
Oh, what's your name, little guy?
My name's Beef and I'm naked.
No, I refuse to believe that's what he sounds like.
Robert, you got a sec.
Sure, yeah.
I'm going to tell him.
Yeah, I'm going to tell him.
He's like, don't tell him.
Don't tell him I cheated.
About the other day with Phenomena Man.
Oh, yeah.
How's dinner?
Oh, it was awkward.
It's why I didn't want you to come.
Phenomena and I...
Oh, wait, she broke up with him?
You were talking to John Sushi?
Yeah.
It's just...
Oh, my God, I have a chance now.
timing felt right I don't know sometimes you just gotta shake shut up it felt a little impulsive but maybe I'm coming it's hard to say what did I contribute I do it oh why would you have contributed to it guess that means I didn't which is what I was hoping for it is what it is over sushi actually not what I wanted to talk to you about I was thinking about it over the weekend and I'm going to cut someone from the Z team.
You want to be rebound?
A fucking course I do.
That's your bro.
She's a muscle mommy.
Urgency.
You sure about that?
Well, less sure now.
You think it's a bad idea?
I'm just not sure how it'll play out.
The reality is cutting someone towards the bottom of the leaderboards will show everyone we're serious.
And they're not at the bottom.
I'll let the team know.
Oh, I already did.
What?
I suppose it'll be an interesting shift.
Oh, they're all going to compete.
Compete it with each other.
Oh, this is a gal.
Yeah, she ain't bad.
Oh.
Did you come over here to tell me that?
Wait, Sonar's second last?
Actually, smart ass.
I came over to tell you that she's second last.
Bro, he was killing it.
Sonar, you all right?
Why are you sending a distress call when you haven't left the building?
Could you send a locksmith downstairs?
What happened?
Coop seduced me.
No.
I said, hey, I want to say something cool.
And then...
So I assumed you meant boobs.
Do you need to make those or mention someone's getting cut, but don't let that distract you from doing a good job out there?
You graduated from Harvard, guys.
What a bunch of bullshit.
Sorry.
What's bullshit?
Which will happen to anyone.
How is that?
Yeah, only God can judge me.
Okay.
False.
no one can judge me but god also false of course i'm being judged along with the rest of you are you do not know what a job is what the hell is going on wait wait it's all right fine just ignore the pressure and do your jobs you don't need to be first you just can't be last uh what about me can somebody go down to the gym and help bat boner who the guy who's shaped like a bat losing feeling in my hand and he was gonna help him kinky way there was an altercation with my team and a monster down at the beach and there's some debris of little giant monster large media and civvy okay so we need someone to be able to move okay we need someone with charisma And,
alright.
There we go.
I think we can pull this off.
Wait, what?
I didn't put you in there.
What?
Okay.
You look different.
On a call with certain slasks, me, Grant Plessed, and I must utter as when Golem is assigned.
Okay.
What?
Watch and learn.
Oh, they're competing now.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Yeah, we can do this.
That's fine.
What?
Go and put laxatives.
Are you serious?
Fight the power.
Force it out of your...
Okay.
Bro, you're working to...
You're not even last.
Mine over focus on the job.
I don't know.
Force it out of your system?
Bro, just fucking poop it out.
yeah no poop it out there's no way force it out man i don't think you can hold it in oh yeah oh thank god okay there we go just just poop that out speakable things in that alley uh-huh you know this is uh really fucking immature guys serves them right you let your guard down you perish what is this what is that's a pretty fucked way to live emphasis on live Oh my god.
You do realize that sabotaging each other isn't going to guarantee you a spot on the team, right?
Oh no.
Oh and he gets...
Okay, there's stats.
If it gets hurt, they'll become...
Okay, that's not good.
Okay.
This is...
Oh gosh.
There's a drug deal happening at the Torn's airport right now.
I think you should send the bat guy.
He's a striking job.
as a buyer.
Preferably someone highly educated on drugs.
Oh, that's Prism.
That's Prism, isn't it?
Yeah, that's...
Soder knows jobs.
Let's send...
I'm going!
Let's send the Prism and send the...
What's done?
Oh, man.
Why?
Bye-bye.
I feel Like, we'll send both of them.
You know, I'll send both of them in.
Sonar and Sonar who is recovering.
Here we go.
Maybe Prism can help him out.
Drug bust.
Fuck yeah.
My two favorite things.
Drugs and booze.
Oh.
Damn.
Seeing all my followers.
Sonar Docs who is now being...
Oh, what?
What?
Surprise drops are good for a brand.
Distract them with a sign.
there you go you got this playing the hits works every time we have to go back oh yeah sonar's getting oh yeah goodbye sonar bro sonar ain't cool so turtle fans moved in flipped to grill starting a fight and and ruined a bunch of hot dogs go on offensive if you have to all right i'll dispatch one guy rise up the ranks around here would everybody please stay in your lanes all right oh wait it wasn't sabotage oh shit we did it be right back just gotta go powder my cocaine nice all right dude you promised me you were gonna come back I will right after this bomb we follow the drug traffickers to base go on strike to bring lots of I'm married for a lot of firepower.
I thought it was like bait shit.
You know?
I don't care.
I thought it was bait.
Combat.
Whatever you say.
Okay.
There we go.
Bring lots of firepower.
That's a lot.
Oh, but then they're like going to sabotage each other.
Why don't I just bring him?
Okay.
Surely if I send three people, they won't sabotage each other.
I feel like all three are going to sabotage each other.
just gonna sabotage each other though i'm pretty sure i don't think i don't yeah yeah i don't know i feel like all three are just gonna sabotage we follow the drug traffickers to their base near the refinery let's shut them down for good
bring three and then maybe they'll be okay all right let's try three let's bring three maybe they won't sabotage all three it's playing a loud sound to death and sonar pain.
He's a grown man bad hybrid.
He can figure it out himself.
Oh my god, track down the source.
I mean, we know it's coop.
We know it's coop.
Can you think he can?
I feel like...
I mean, what is he gonna do after he tracks her down?
Plug your ears.
You'll be fine.
You're not big... Yeah.
You can plug it up.
You cannot plug it up.
Get up.
He cannot.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay guys.
Oh my god.
Okay
You know what I just kind of wanted to know if he could become one with it prideful okay incorporate into your body You're now you're now clay cement golem It's fine you can't get double hurt He can in fact get double hurt
He can indeed.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Just made it in.
Thank God.
That was too close.
That was so close.
Okay.
Hey, my grandma just got scammed by someone claiming they work for you guys.
Better intel on the scam and scammer.
Okay.
Social security numbers.
All the bad numbers.
Speak to it all, Victor.
You know what?
I can send...
I don't know who's best friends with each other.
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
Let's see it.
We'll put... more charisma.
And... you know what?
Charisma.
There you go.
Alright, oh they work together.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, that's not good.
We know that's good.
They work together.
Oh god, this is...
Scary?
Alright, that's good.
That's good, guys.
We're all proud of you.
We're all so proud of you.
Alright, uh...
Intel Gathering.
I feel like you gotta be smart for that, right?
Oh, but I don't have a smart person.
I mean...
Maybe?
You two work well together.
You got someone that can figure out how to stop a landslide?
As hot and threatening as that sounds.
I'm not going anywhere.
We're tied for the bottom with fucking invisigal.
Not for long.
Alright, so reinforced.
Oh, okay, you guys.
Wait, but you guys hate each other.
Dude.
I mean, oh my gosh.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
You guys hate each other.
It's okay.
It's... I'm fine with it.
that it's okay surely it'll be okay oh my god okay so did i push me in the pool during the they refused to let me leave i hate the water and old people signed your death warrant worth it next time don't promise a man boobs no one promised you anything describe your diarrhea earlier so when i pushed me in the pool during the water they refused to let me leave i hate the water and old people.
Do I just backstroke away?
Or do I describe backstroke away?
Maybe I can swim away.
Where is that?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I know I have a lot of mobility.
I just swam away.
You should really see my butterfly stroke.
Alright.
The Ticket roll has turned into the mascot Inquisition.
Cash up with the rowdy's hands.
This suit is too hot.
Okay, oh, Shit.
All my fast people are... God.
Oh, wait.
Whoa, here.
Catch up.
And I remember he was chill.
He was chill with me.
I'm going already.
He was chill with her.
Yeah.
They were chill like that.
What happened?
She's fine.
Just walked into my sword with her face a little bit.
I don't believe in punching women.
But I do believe in punching demons.
I mean...
understandable understand she is they look like oh come on charlie oh wait we made it oh thank god thank god tomorrow also wait but you guys were chill nobody sabotages me except me you guys were chill i'll unlock the tape bro what the fuck i sent you two together why were you why did you guys not be chill until I close the lid they would chill like that I remembered they like hang down at everything there we go like what happened yeah yeah what the fuck did you do and wow coming over God chill still got it like I remember I remember he was fine.
What the fuck happened?
Alright.
Left, down, down.
Yeah, just take your fucking time.
Don't worry, you're okay.
Left, down, down.
There you go.
Emergency unlock, activate.
Palazar, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I spoke too soon.
Drowning in a sensory deprivation tank is not the kind of wet I like to be, Robert.
I still... I don't know what... I don't know their chemistry.
I still don't know.
Oh.
Let's put it here.
Let's boost their best stats.
Lambay is friends with...
Okay, Prism.
Okay.
Can we get some help over here?
The lot is packed.
No one moved in like an hour.
Oh, that's for Prism.
Okay.
A bandco cyber train with precious cargo aboard is minutes away from colliding with the stopped freight and the station.
the precious okay um halt the train before it crashes I assume defense right yeah defense and charisma all right who is punch up friends with invisigal and golem yeah but they're yeah golem is out golem ain't coming in golem is out out is punch up and coop or punch up and coop are friends all right that's good you're not gonna like what you see anyway this one i need prism prism
oh thank god oh thank god i'm like whoa i'm luck is on my side today so uh holy fuck hey so like my friend's boyfriend was like bragging about how he pretends to be sdn and scams people he's a real piece of deliver the says looking for it not a fight.
Okay, first up we're gonna put we're gonna put prism in here.
Okay.
And then, you know what?
Bro, is prism and sonar cool?
I don't know.
Hmm.
Prism and flamb- Oh, it's gone?
No, it's not.
It's right here.
Oh, shit!
Sonar Invis Wait, are they good, friends?
Oh my god
Guys No?
Oh, fuck, okay Fine The hell, man Oh, no Oh, no Okay, here Come on, I was about to click that Okay, it's going so fast.
It's going so fast.
Sure thing.
I forgot who they're friends with.
How's my hair?
Perfect as always.
Are they friends?
You smell weird.
Trying on a new cologne.
Oh, they're friends.
Stop trying this.
They're friends.
Oh, God.
Come on.
I think I'm going to use me head.
He cannot be... Oh, yeah, he doesn't... Yeah, it's alright.
That's good.
You got two!
That was okay.
Soder's not gonna die.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
Not only wasn't it our guy, but we let the other creep escape.
Bro, you went to Harvard!
Soder!
Half man, half bad, all freak.
You went to Harvard!
How do you fuck?
Fuck this up, bro!
Okay, surely she doesn't fuck this up for me.
God, okay, thank God.
Bad bitch, no stopping me.
Thank God, I knew I could count on Flamb and Prism.
Heading towards the only street.
Really?
Oh, she needs it.
Fuck off.
What are you doing in Visigal?
Yeah, what are you doing?
It's like you said the way to win this leaderboard game is to not lose, right?
Yeah, that's not what I said I'm pretty sure that's what you said
I'm thinking I'm the oh my god I'm cooking too much Wait, that's sabotage bitch Oh shit
What the fuck is going on?
Lightning struck.
No shit?
That's crazy.
Don't piss off the fucking demons.
Oh shit.
I'd normally say cut her, but the way things are going, I'd cut the whole damn team.
You need a reset, Robbie.
All Z team back to base and in the conference room in 20 minutes.
11 calls.
Lack of team.
What?
It didn't even matter.
Is this scripted?
Is this scripted because I failed?
Happens.
Oh, it's scripted.
Okay, it's not me.
It's not me.
It's not my fault.
It's scripted.
Thank God.
I knew I wasn't the issue
It's not my fault
Anyone else think this is a waste of time?
Yeah, I know Like what are we doing?
What the fuck is the point is?
Try to be somewhere else.
I had a thousand better things to do.
There is so I look at it to me if I'm welcome welcome I'm playing them DPS Can everybody count romantic like look at her?
Hey, can I get your attention?
please i would like to get started so oh shit oh looks like this i'll get the power to fly that's it call him get out hey you get out get out of here yeah you yeah barney rubble off you can ask he's gotta know i'm in charge here then i won't just kick you out of this room i'll kick you out of the whole phoenix program You can go back to whatever life was so lame that you thought coming here was an improvement or you can step outside and think that's fucking right Why you're here something everyone in this room should be thinking about
That's right you understand bro That's fucking right How am I rude He fucking slammed me in He's got to learn He's gotta learn.
I'm not gonna let him push me around.
What's this shit about?
Let's go.
Come on.
If I can waste my time, let's go.
Okay, as you know, by the end of today, one of you will be cut from the Z team.
This is bullshit.
Yeah, you said that already.
Call me from a job I didn't want in the first place.
Miss Blazer, maybe if you gave us a dispatcher who knew what they were doing, you wouldn't have to throw no one out.
Hey, Nikki Mirage, I'm standing right here.
You can talk to me.
Whoa!
Which weak-ass superhero team did you come from?
Fucking geek squad?
Doesn't matter where I'm from, Cardi C.
What matters is I'm here to figure out who stays and who goes.
Yeah, chill, old lady.
Ha ha.
That's the man's hard.
Okay, what?
Damn.
You hipster motherfucker?
Over here looking like Mumford fucked all his sons.
That's not a bad leader?
That was funny.
See?
We're just busting balls.
Keep talking.
You won't have your tiny inbred balls left to bust.
Ask next time.
Where there won't be a next time.
Don't threaten me, you butt and I, bitch.
Oh, shit.
No, they're just bad people.
Most people will look around.
They're not fixable.
That's why.
And see a bunch of villains.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just not fixable.
Not even super kind.
Just plain ass.
It's not my fault.
Run in the mill, vanilla fucking villains.
But that's not what I see.
Because lucky for you, I'm not most people.
When I look around this room, what I see is...
Potential.
both are in the end unfortunately for you it's a curse because there isn't a thing in the universe that goes more wasted than potential and despite how common it is no one seems to forget it's what they whisper when you leave the room oh so and so had so much potential it follows you forever i'm here to help you lift the curse of potential by getting you to fucking do something with it
the phoenix program any of you know what a phoenix is oh um city in arizona yeah the sweltering ball sack of america nah then louisiana's got to be the ball sack just you know position the phoenix sorry attention man that was so tired of its immortality it tricked the sun god into dropping a spark on its nest to set it ablaze burning it to shit but instead of dying the phoenix emerged from ash Look,
I give them tough love and then, like, glaze them up.
All of you in this room are phoenixes, and it's obvious what that means.
But for you dumb ones, I'll spell it out.
I'm bad cop, good cop.
I'm both.
Redemption.
That's what you're here for, is what connects everyone in this room.
To burn up who you were, to become who you were meant to be.
You bad go, I'm kind of listening to this.
Phoenix is also a lame-ass band my lame-ass roommate listens to.
You're late.
I like that band.
I was here the whole time.
I turned invisible genius, remember?
Move it.
Great.
Then you know we're cutting someone, and you, Miss Hot Topic Sale, are at the bottom of the leaderboards.
Have a better second shift.
Oh.
What for a coup?
We all know you'll just be working the roulette wheel.
That's a croupier, you idiot.
The fuck's a croupier.
I'm just saying, you're a degenerate gambler.
Oh, it's a second shift time?
oh are they gonna work together now thanks all right everyone you heard the man get out there and do some stellar dispatching you've got this are they gonna work together now guys huh what is this take a hero out of resting okay i just filled him up coffee check the info for tags what tags oh defender versatile okay
Alright, this is 5.
Nah, he's cool.
Look, he's not cool.
My client requires protection while he does some shopping.
I remember this man.
And he's right to be paranoid.
Secret police hired me three years ago to kill him.
He pissed off the wrong dictator.
Protect the subscriber from ancient while he shops.
He can protect.
What?
Call him.
There you go, Golem.
Protect the...
I feel like I need...
Bigger, right?
I was...
Yo, he's fine.
See?
I put him back in.
Prepare to fend off any incoming attack.
I feel like I should...
Be prepared.
Yeah, I feel like...
Fine.
There you go.
Yeah, he should be fine.
No, he's fine.
See?
He can't be Ingy.
You just gotta force him to work.
Yeah, and he has defense.
Some bitch just cut me in line at the Utopia concert.
I've been here for 12 fucking hours.
Utopia is a hack.
I like her.
You basic bat.
You've got super hearing and you use it to listen to a girl who knows four chords and can't write a song to save her life say what you want it's catchy unbelievable i feel i need someone what charisma
sonar i guess i could yeah intelligence yeah let's do it guess what i found out last night the sdn office all right did you do okay or cia prison in torrents okay 73 that's sick the odds are in my favor there you go golem okay that's that now you maybe you won't get cut now put that in why is there like there's an extra somewhere i don't know where see that right there's some oh there oh she just got it okay you know i'll make you a little smarter yo mao what kind of music you got in your heavy rotation right now you know honestly it's a lot of skull but i had like a really big okay what happened now recently too dang Oh.
Anything good you'd recommend?
Depends.
Do you like the sensation of your ears bleeding?
I knew I should put prism.
I'm good.
All right.
All for me.
Oh, I knew I should have put prism.
Uh, serenade her.
Do we have enough?
That's charisma, right?
Yeah, that's charisma.
Fuck, I knew it.
I was thinking.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, we have a lot.
I was thinking that was charisma.
And that's how we do it down under.
All right, we have an upgrade, too.
You know what?
We'll put you some combat as well.
Won't be bad.
Can't be too bad to be able to fight.
There's some kind of cult recruiting outside my store.
They're creeping everyone up.
Tell them to disperse immediately.
Who's smart enough for that?
I feel like that's on it.
Charism, right?
Wait.
That's charisma.
And what to identify them.
So by identifying, we use our brain.
So, who has more brain?
Are you kidding?
What?
You don't like her?
Since when?
I'm gonna make you like her.
I think there's also some kind of cult recruiting outside my store.
They're creeping everyone out.
Why don't you like her?
That's fine.
We don't need it.
Melvonia.
Free their minds.
I feel like that's intelligence.
Destroy their literature.
I don't know what...
Free their minds would be the...
The brain.
But I don't think...
I don't think I have enough...
I don't think I have enough, guys.
Because, like...
I have four.
I feel like destroy would...
be combat, right?
I have enough for combat.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That's right.
Burn the books!
I'm your hero, baby.
Burn it on!
That's right!
Yeah!
Burn it!
We don't need their book.
For some kind of fight club.
Shut down the underground fight club.
Anticipate resistance.
Alright.
You can fight What do you think you can shut this down?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, you're fine.
I think you guys are good friends, right?
You know what?
We can get two.
We don't need three.
Whatever you say, boss.
Fight in that fight club.
I still think this is a waste of time.
Don't worry, guys.
We'll watch this fight happen.
I'm going to bet for my team.
But he's still alive.
Protect the subscriber while he has lunch.
Be prepared to fend off any incoming attack.
I remember last time we got golden no cash no kill wait what SDN's always paid on time and in full so as long as the checks clear I will kill or protect all right there you go our men let us kill people around here who been men they see fit I feel like these two golden with invis why
what's up big guy hey what's up little lady yeah look at it they have synergy oh that's why
I don't think he's gonna make it.
Oh, yeah, no, 100%.
Thank God.
I'm on it.
There you go.
We won the fight club.
We did it, guys.
We won.
Oh, yeah, that's 100.
Let's go.
How'd you manage this one?
Yeah, I don't want to talk about it.
I've learned from my sources.
Where's she going?
The next tournament will be held at the refinery.
in one hour.
Why didn't the fight club?
Bro, fight in it!
Robert, send me in to compete.
I'll win so hard.
We'll bankrupt every bookie in Torrance.
Bro, let's do it.
You're so right.
Don't worry, give me a sec.
Now we're fighting in this.
Wait, what?
You're a training.
Well, officially.
Legally.
Your flight-capable heroes need a flight license.
That's fine.
Go to a fly school.
No, we don't need to use coffee yet.
See, I told you.
at him or four is five bro he is bored to fight you can't get hurt and we can win money too leaderboard thing goes away and we could also win money but how do you think they feel about menacing threats let's go let him do what he wants desperate oh did he got his license lamblay flies greatly reducing oh nice that reduces travel time My client requires protection at the Torrance Pier.
Prepare to protect the subscribe.
Wait, who did I do?
Cav for that?
These two, right?
Yeah.
Fucking rocks.
Using your symbols on your corner.
Or maybe a coup help, punch up.
All right, yeah, help him out.
Fuck it, let's go.
25.
Uh, what?
This is our 25th time being paired together.
Let's go.
I am.
And then, with me there, welcome to Lindsay's Center.
Get in the air with the bone zone.
Participate in a friendly debate.
I know who it is.
It's on my radar.
Look at.
These two like each other.
Oh, my God.
These two.
I always forget.
I've got better things to do anyway.
Want to dance?
They're okay with each other, right?
I think they are.
Oh, Sonar and Mel.
Oh, that's fine.
Right back at you.
There you go.
I keep forgetting who they're friends with.
Oh?
Sorry.
Don't worry, we got Invisagirl here.
Fuckers didn't even see me coming.
Oh, the sabotage is over?
Does it happen again?
Do they ever sabotage again?
Your position at the top of the leaderboard.
Don't be jealous.
I took a little peek at your file.
Apparently you've got more fire than anyone else on the team.
I'm like a psychic man.
I can sense where they're going to be before they happen.
Listen, listen, there's a lot of potential here for a good health insurance scheme.
Wait.
You just need a middleman.
I could be your guy.
Interesting.
We did it.
We won Fight Club.
Let's go.
We got bonus checks.
Hold up.
Hold the fuck up.
Punch.
I told.
Look at that, guys.
Guys, in two minutes.
We got, we got bonus checks.
We got, it's a Christmas bonus early.
Oh.
Punch-ups got a, uh, special.
technique real classy stuff maybe if you ask nice i'll tell you about it my lips are sealed look at that i knew it i knew we can get oh plus synergy oh nice a hero training i got some who needs extra training what does it do wait we'll just wait a little bit urgent care on bigfield street go quickly Oh,
don't underestimate him.
He hits hard.
Okay, we need to figure this out.
Oh, it gives new abilities?
Oh!
I see.
Half man, half bat, all freak.
Wait, who has new upgrades?
Oh, wait.
We'll grab more combat because you are a fighter.
Oh, God, there's a lot.
Help!
I am at the door.
Oh, it's back and there's these guys with masks and guns.
Oh, God.
We'll use Prism, right?
Uh, I don't know.
I want to...
We'll give you some stuff.
Um...
Oh, everyone is not...
Oh, okay.
We're going to have to put some coffee for someone.
Why can't I use this?
Oh, Shadini!
Okay, whatever.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
I still have time.
Oh, okay.
No, no way I'm doing that.
What?
On my way.
Oh.
Are you see...
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Brace yourselves.
I don't think he needs anyone.
All right.
I don't see gender.
Oh, you're just gonna get cut.
Fuck it.
I'm cutting you.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, this is bad.
I already tangled with this dickwad once.
Send someone else.
All right.
This is five.
It's Thundercock.
All right.
Trap the robbers.
It's okay.
We got...
Good luck, golem.
You can solo this.
Golem, sweet.
I believe.
It's a golem, sweet.
There you go.
Oh, that is...
Oh, now I get why you guys said it gets harder.
That is weirdo.
Oh, my God.
I don't remember.
Well, it's the last one.
What is the last one?
Guys, no!
Guys, what was...
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we got this.
We got it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yay!
We're a team, everyone.
This is a team.
game.
Yappy!
I believe he can solo this.
This is... I still believe.
My car is about to the prism creates an illusion that keeps for a few more.
This happens.
Prisms now have the full stats of the copy.
Oh, I like that.
I I think he can solo this.
My man, Golems, got it.
Okay, Golems.
Oh, man.
Oh, I can't redo on that one.
It's okay.
It's all right.
Pretty breathtaking work back there.
Not too shabby.
You know, it's not our fault.
It's like we're working.
Four failures?
As a theme.
Uh-huh.
Baby, that's got a name.
What did I get?
Isn't that like a sex thing?
What type of sex thing would that be?
It's not really a sexual...
It's her fault.
You know.
I'll text it to you.
All right, nice.
Oh, damn, boy.
That's some fucking teamwork.
All right.
Yeah.
Let's give him word.
Invisigaw, where are you going?
It's not my fault.
What's going on?
Is she depressed?
Because I'm going to keep fire her?
Smoking in a playground.
What the fuck's wrong with you?
There you go.
One more strike against me.
You gotta get rid of somebody, right?
I'm making it easy for you.
You're quitting.
You're not making it easy for me.
Yeah, why is she smoking with asthma?
You don't get it.
Some people are born to be heroes.
I'm not one of them.
I tried.
Just wasn't meant to be.
Meant to be.
You didn't even try that hard!
Oh, you didn't even try that hard.
Flying through the sky.
Nothing to hide.
What's your point?
Yeah, that was a freaky conversation.
I have fucking villain powers.
I can turn invisible and skulk in the shadows.
Yeah, but you can give intel.
And watch famous people fuck.
Yeah, villain is my fate.
I watch.
You can just film it.
It's in the fucking stars.
And then sell it.
You know... In the same way that blonde blazer was always meant to be a hero.
It is bullshit.
It's bullshit.
It's just something we cling to because we think we're the main...
Oh, I shouldn't have said that.
Or a bunch of flesh blobs with depression on a floating rock.
Is that supposed to be comforting?
Yeah, because no one's paying attention if you want to switch things up.
You've already been a hero, okay?
You have no idea what I'm dealing with.
Oh, get out of here.
At least you were born with powers.
I don't have shit.
So according to your dumbass theory, I should be an accountant.
You aren't far off.
fate destiny not having power she's into it guys me talking down on her being a hero before and they won't keep me from what's that weird where you compliments you insult them and then compliment them being a hero again it's working on her i'm in oh it's him again i got you want to talk about fate that lightning struck that's been on a spree is two blocks from your location maybe it's Yeah,
I'm doing backhanded compliment.
I'm out.
Oh, yeah, I'm nagging.
What makes you think it'd be any different?
You're pissed.
I get it.
You know what I like to do when I'm pissed?
Punch things.
Often, bad people.
I do like to punch things.
I know.
You're great at it.
Go be great one more time.
Yeah.
And if you kill him, that's a bonus.
One less criminal on the road.
Don't do it.
that kid a cigarette what's the address shut the fuck up okay sorry i know it's like my immersion but that reminded me i was like walking down the street one time and i think it was i think it was valentine's day i think and i was walking down the street to buy some buy some stuff for dad and i think i forgot to tell you guys the story but this kid like walked up to me and was like can you buy me alcohol for like my girlfriend and i for that like he was holding like a he was holding like i didn't give a child so he was holding like uh like like a like a bunch of flowers like bouquet of flowers and this kid went up to me and was like can you buy us buy me alcohol for me and my girlfriend for valentine's day i
don't know how old he was like i'll pay you I'll pay you back but like like I'll give you like I'll give you like double the money you can buy me it for he
said no but that's what it reminded me of like I said no I didn't want to get arrested like bro we were like it was day it was day outside like I'm probably not gonna fight give this kid I don't know how old he is like I would if I said yes I would have not this story on stream because that's me admitting to a crime live on stream like of course i didn't fucking do it why the would i admit it on stream if i did but that's just what that's what it provided me of yeah i
don't know how old he is like he like i know he was underage Not underage, but you have to be...
Yeah, yeah, because in Canada, it's 18.
So he was definitely underage, so if he's asking me to buy him alcohol, I don't remember that.
Where's your boy?
Shit.
He's like, in America, it's 21, but in Canada it's 18.
So I was like, that's worse, you know?
You...
Donut, girl.
You sure you want to do this again?
He wasn't even gonna pay you.
No, he was gonna give me money first.
I mean, I could have just taken the money and just left.
But...
I'm flying blind here.
I can't see anything.
What's going on?
Great.
Give me a second to tap into this.
Oh shit, the hack again.
Oh, it's not time though this time.
Thank god.
I'm laughing out of stress.
A little more tricky.
Sure, take your time.
What?
I need quiet.
Oh!
I was like so confused.
I was like, what is that?
There was not enough time for me to...
What is it?
Antivirus.
There you are.
Okay, now there's antivirus too.
Okay.
Got it.
I can see you again.
That makes one of us...
Four minute crime on stream, press...
By the way, there's something she's not telling us.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ruchi, thank you for the super chat.
Okay, now we gotta be smart.
Okay.
I guess I could do this too.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Oh, I'm fucked.
Okay, nice.
JK, I'm gaming.
JK, I'm still gaming.
Ignoring what I...
Ignoring me fucking that up.
He's at your seven.
That wasn't so hard, was it?
He's heading your way.
Master your life.
And this is the guy I got a plan.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I can only be caught once, I guess.
Oh, what?
Okay.
Fuck you, fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
I gotta use my brain for that.
I looped him.
Looped a loop.
On the count of three, I'm going to turn on the main overhead lights, which should temporarily blind him giving you a chance to take him out.
One, two, three.
See, I saved our life now she'll remember this.
Oh shit.
Choke him!
Yeah!
Got this!
Break his neck!
I'm no hero.
Fuck, no, let me try that again.
Wait, uh, what about...
Move, let me retry this.
Nice.
That's the one.
Would have been better if you said it first.
Right, just lightning thunder.
Just cut it.
Just edit it out.
Like how Mr. Beast edited his teeth.
You guys know that?
That's crazy.
What is it called?
Teeth gate?
Hey, bangle boy!
More like bangle bitch!
Or bitch boy!
Hey bangle bitch boy, fuck you!
Yeah, catchphrases aren't easy, guys.
It takes a while to build your catchphrase.
Why are those assholes not being assholes?
Isn't this what you were going for?
Yeah, they're a team.
They're cheering for their teammates.
So this one keeps the comm line one-on-one.
This one connects to the whole team.
And this one goes out to the entire brain.
Oh!
Good job.
Yeah, you got off light.
one dispatcher broadcast the details of his botched circumcision hr nightmare wait but nobody stopped me you really think she has a shot nobody went up to me sounded good but everyone has a shot no if you were just saying what you thought she needed to hear see i'm i'm nagging everyone has a shot people are who they choose to be if invisigal wants this she has to commit it's too easy to quit when you're not good at something now i just got compliment golem next and now he and now they're like deeply indebted to me hot and cold guys that was great this mission was textbook genuinely dude i'm really happy for you so it's between sonar and coop what sonar cool and visigal still at the bottom of the board oh the one in the bullpen that thing updates every hour and visigal moved up catching lightning struck really gave her a huge boost bangle boy real really the donut shop escape slipping past a malevola now the jewelry store really bumped up the wanted levels it's like missing the free
throw on purpose to get the put back yeah exactly i don't watch football but i get it bro i already invested i know i already invested so much on sonar guys on the bottom i'm not sure i'd have let you cut her that is a good thing she's not yeah so these two are now tied for last place guys there's the thing is i gave coop nothing i gave charlie all my stats i support it all the way wait wait the person i pick is the person i'm cutting right i just want to know i need to know whoever i'm choosing is the one i cut it and you know in case i accidentally be fucking up because i thought whoever i'm picking is whoever i'm keeping but we all know who we're keeping because 2025 is his year guys 2025 if i'm honest you still feels a little meh that's too bad all right i'll get started on the paperwork 2025 is his year guys feels important hey uh robert gotta end the cycle great work today
Hoop, I'm sure you already know why I've asked you here.
You would be mistaken.
Oh, okay.
Um, well, I'm letting you go.
You're at the bottom of the leaderboards.
I guess all those penalties for, you know, cutting people, added up.
I'm sorry.
But I cheered for Invisagal.
You did.
I saw that.
We all cheered.
I only did that because I thought she was being cut.
Whoa.
That makes sense.
A lot of sense, actually.
Yeah, well, she snuck past her with her last dispatch.
Oh.
That's, uh...
Oh, look at that.
That's very menacing.
Well, thank you.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
Maybe there are other superhero agencies out there.
You know?
Maybe there's other agencies that she can sign up for.
It can't be only one.
Right?
I just keep that.
You accessorizing?
You could call it that.
Where'd you get that?
Coop.
It's not bad to fire a heart ex-accessant, right?
One is just the bat.
The other one was an ex-accessant.
So I don't know if I made the right choice, guys.
You're spoiling him.
Not safe.
Talk about it.
You ready to go home, bud?
Oh, nothing bad will come out of this, I'm pretty sure.
Who's the bottom now?
Oh.
She's like, yeah.
Where is she on the...
Oh, she's third last.
Guys, as not, like, we're taking a picture of.
Third...
Guys, I'm third last!
Let's go!
I'm sorry.
I look, you're like, aww not last not last not last let's go
big chungus i want i won't work for big chungus though
like everyone's like oh and i'm like why the fuck is she taking a picture
Her being last is sort of, like, her fault, though.
Because she was self-sabotaging herself, so.
UN64.
Yeah, no one cuts Charlie.
Oh, this.
UN23% of players kick all of...
Why did you guys...
Oh, you guys are too soft.
You are all too soft, man.
We're teaching him a fucking lesson.
You're all too soft.
Okay, it helped.
Who the fuck did not help me?
Wait.
Oh, if you don't have...
helper, you get to keep both of them, right?
Wait.
The other one was, uh, wait, who the fuck, wait, does it mean like, if you don't, oh, oh, you failed the hacking.
Okay.
So all of you are Phoenixes.
You and a player said fate is bullshit.
Oh, but that was a good choice, though.
I said a good thing.
You guys said, why do you help them escape with no Two times you and 18% of players said punch up like you successfully protected victory.
That's funny What none of you guys fucking joined the fight club guys?
We we got both we got a Christmas bonus now chat.
Yeah I can't believe it Your most said hero is so now you perform better.
Yeah, average Yippee
You made him solo it.
Oh, you solo.
Because nobody talks about bike love.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
We mama.
Ah.
Oh.
Oh my god, okay Oh gosh, oh god Oh my god Oh my god, is that me?
Fuck, oh, okay, it was a dream Okay, okay, oh Okay, oh Okay, okay, okay okay okay all right oh my gosh guys this is why okay yeah no no fuck okay people are like you gotta put the sensor on you gotta you gotta not use the sensor i i i don't know how the fuck i could get got away with that i oh my gosh okay
I'm glad I'm glad I put the sensor on I'm glad
This is why the game is popular Psycho.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't remember guys.
We get all of this
What the fuck?
Guys we get all of all It's a sensor.
I don't know why it's sensor Oh my god.
We get all of that, but yet the models aren't public.
They hit the models.
Koop was a friend of his.
They used to date.
Oh.
My last girlfriend was taller than me.
She used to kiss me on my forehead a lot.
It was nice.
What are we talking about?
Oh, right.
Oh, poor dad.
The problem with only cutting one of them is now you gotta deal with their pissy friends poisoning the rest of the team.
Come on, Chase.
It's harmless.
Who doesn't love an office prank?
Me, motherfucker.
Don't even think about it.
That's why I would have cut them all.
Start them with that asshole.
Which one?
Invisible gal, but she...
Why is she staring at you?
She had a horny dream of me.
Don't you got some dementia to onset?
That's why the models are locked.
Bro, you can't lock the models if you're part of the problem.
You can't lock the model if you're part of the problem.
You should think about who you want.
tell what if the one who animated that was uh what am i missing was animating some stuff on what's it called the overwatch models they want to be the only supplier he looks rough oh oh god god god damn it water boy sorry yeah you can tell whoever animated that was an sfm a animator.
They regret it not adding more scenes like that.
Thank you, thank you.
Good thing, because it's the only reason anyone gave your sorry ass a job.
Water boy used...
To be fair, water gun is basically that.
It's... Jesus.
Yeah, I understand.
Protocols test 7.
pilot ready we good out there that's crazy that I'm testing it myself like what if it fucking explodes
system power
simple locomotion complex locomotion like what if the thing explodes we onto something bro you know what let's do jumping jacks this is gonna be it let's go that's intensive as hell what One, two, three, four, five.
Well, if I can't even do jumping jacks, this shit is fucked.
Frap, can't even pass the E class.
Protopulse test seven, failure.
No worries, we'll get there.
Roy,
what is all this stuff?
The whole network expect me to process all the confiscated stuff.
Because we're the bottom branch for SDN.
We catch all kinds of shit work, bro.
Bro, she's checking out my flat ass.
We take one bad guy stuff and use them for catch the other bad guy.
Only good thing?
A lot of upgrade possibilities.
off in this thing i mean why do you why do you want to know would you be asking how often yeah i gotta work on this maybe i have maybe i haven't what's it to you just want to know why the buttons are sticky damn what the she's joking royd in her very specific off-putting oh she's so into me oh she likes it she likes the bad energy going on bro she likes it she likes that bad thing the mother place i got work yeah robert was just leaving look at that tension that's gonna be tough because blazer sent me to get you like half an hour ago sir robert will remember this but he doesn't want to i'm forcing him to remember this
whoa shit blazer sorry um you know what i can come back oh no don't worry i got this But you're still wearing a mask?
It's not why you're here, but can you zip me up?
Oh, sure.
It's not mine.
By the way, they make me wear it, then it's back in a bag by midnight.
What is happening today?
Yeah.
What's happening today?
The thing you're going to.
SDN sponsoring a dinner gala thing.
Radiant Valor, a night of triumph.
Why does that sound like a propaganda rally?
There.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It does kind of sound like some sort of fascist-themed prom.
What do you think?
Someone was like secret identities, but I fucking...
You have your hair sticking out, and yet the bottom half of your face, and you can see the eyes.
You're not hiding anything.
Oh, hey, there's a nipple out.
Your ariola is showing.
No cause for alarm, but a little bit of your ariola is out.
It's like a slight hue shift.
You might as well take that mask off.
I don't think I've heard someone say Ariola out loud before.
It doesn't come up a ton, though.
All right.
For real now.
How do I look?
The breakup story is out, so I might be getting more attention.
You look incredible, girl.
I think you look incredible.
Thanks.
I was supposed to be going with him, but I don't think he's going to be making it.
The downtown branch dropped him.
Indefinite suspension.
what is that your car and why did they drop him that's gonna be a weird insurance claim i'd like for you to talk to him me what why me you're the pep talk guy you've been through a transition recently yourself i think he could use some perspective like perspective to join the z team chase mentioned it yeah the only candidates that make sense are him or water boy and at the moment it's yeah but he could drive drown himself in i'd like you to get him out of the parking lot you drown himself in work stop with the edible arrangements he keeps sending them but with all melon that's disgusting oh i'll see what i can do might as well just send the strawberries i mean i'm allergic to strawberries but i know that people from what i'm told strawberries taste good i don't know though i'll never know how you doing bud i have been better robert robertson the blonde blazer and i have ended our relationship Yeah,
I heard about that.
I'm sorry for your, you know, your loss.
It's very abrupt.
One moment we were savoring uni straight from the urchin.
Next moment, I'm contemplating flying into the sun.
What's stopping you?
Absorbing all its energy and casting this planet into infinite darkness.
Okay, yeah, no, don't do that.
Yeah, no.
Maybe then I would be free of the torment in my soul.
I've had those days.
I've been there last time I went to a breakup.
I drank mezcal, I blacked out.
When I came to I was in a dark void surrounded by the smell of rot and I was convinced I died and turned into a zombie.
Turns out I passed out at a urinal and somebody threw me in a dumpster.
Thank you for sharing that.
You aren't sad enough to understand.
See, we're just... Whoa!
Do you think there is someone else?
Perhaps another lover could be the cause of all this.
Maybe she met a person.
I kissed her.
An actual person.
I am not a person.
I just resemble one hand.
It was me.
Look, I'm not a man.
I'm only telling you this because I don't want you hearing it from someone else.
Yeah.
I kiss Blazer.
It was me.
That's right.
Before you incinerate me, it's worth noting.
I had no idea she was in a relationship.
This happened while we were together.
It just gets worse.
That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
You're a superhero.
And I'm a normal guy.
And then I kissed him.
Not to blame for my sadness.
Maybe, but I doubt it.
It was me.
I guess this is something she was thinking about for a while.
It was me, Flash.
I'm not that good of a kisser.
Oh, shit.
No, is he actually going to kill me?
Wait.
And I can't remember.
Bro, I could have remixed her and him!
Wait, am I that bad of a kisser?
Bro, I have a girl that's having horny dreams of me.
There's no way.
Oh, shit.
Aw, I can't even fly.
My kiss check failed.
I rolled a zero.
I didn't even know that was possible.
Where's the shootout?
The dice, like, exploded when I tried.
try to roll it a desk job would have me bleeding this often
what are you doing here i had a dream last night that we were fucking huh usually i don't remember my dreams but this one did i was my dick big was it the one where i have a big dick yeah nice i gotta do i gotta do it being with someone you know see how it feels how it looks you know like trying on a dress you were there i could have been i just wanted to know it was above average anywhere oh oh it's kind of gross really you chose to be here really god damn it water boy i try not to do that don't worry about it water boy that sound bathrooms are for shitting after your first coffee and picking shrapnel out of your chest not for whatever this is you ruined this for me
my apologies
got water blocked right to thank you the super chat thank you thank you strawberries and benedro goes hard what do you mean oh hey okay you want to get fatter let's go Oh, God.
You're a mess.
I'm a problem.
Hello, guys.
We're ready for work?
Oh, we're missing one person now.
It's weird that Koop's gone.
Glad you made the cut, though, dude.
Imagine if it was Koop and Vizzy together.
I imagine Koop and Vizzy all the time.
Help us get this stuff out of the dorm.
Yeah.
You guys do that kind of stuff?
Those that carry the bot lines.
All right, here.
you got this you're strong yeah I believe I've been hearing a lot about some guy named Chad I think he's trying to summon a demon he's like punch up his catapult anyway I'm gonna send him out yeah
send join the club I mean I do know where the church is I could snoop around let's do it alright send to directly oh can I send more people You know what?
Fuck it.
Aren't you persistent?
Easy enough.
Guess what?
Oh, yeah.
Should I send two?
Or so not?
Oh, you're right.
I forgot they have perfect synergy.
I may not be everyone's taste, but I am a lot of people.
This guy in front of me just drove right off and he did not rush them to the hospital.
Okay, someone we can run.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, I follow.
You two can go.
He didn't do stuff together.
That's fine.
Hoping people is actually really cool.
Unless it's an annoying person.
It's third and seven.
Oh, wait.
Actually, let's do this.
Let's check them out.
Oh, this is not good.
Oh.
That's a bruise to me, prayed.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Okay.
Can you look into their tax filings?
Oh, man.
They're definitely up to no good.
Oh, no.
They're committing tax fraud?
How could there is it?
That's a crime.
Guys, don't do that.
All right.
Admiral, thank you for the rage.
Thank you.
Let's get the charisma up still.
Time to freak someone else.
Oh, there you go.
Um...
I need more combat.
Okay.
And seven in the UCT red zone, and tensions have boiled over into a full-on...
Remove the troublemakers.
Okay, I'm gonna grab coffee.
And...
Fresh as a daisy.
All right, there you go.
You two.
I believe.
What's it going to be this time?
I believe in you two.
Okay, fly them to the hospital.
We have a flyer.
I feel like you didn't look.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank God I got the right person.
dude shit why do you need it you're in the field i just want to make sure it's there it's a very nice stapler i should upgrade the other stuff now this is jason from nostalgia alley someone just dropped off a box of games of the no search through the inbound inside one of them disarm a bomb okay well where the hell did you go job's not finished dude we need you to bring everything up to our new place.
Unload the heavy furniture and boxes into the new...
Carry the blinds up for flights of stairs.
Who was it that I told to do that?
I don't remember.
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
Well, wait a little bit because I don't have people right now.
Alright, search through.
Okay.
gosh I mean you can do that I've got the bandwidth it's two for one oh that's true okay we'll send these two out there and then check out that ramen shop bro you get so cranky oh this is bad change oh I can put special power man oh there we go there you go we're doing it guys i'm learning it we need you to send somebody else this is too much we're out of somebody's you're gonna have to make do you sound like okay we made it i fired his ass no no no no no okay thank god you rob it we made it i knew you guys got this this would be a breeze i can't believe i'm saying this but oh point noted can you in there a little longer.
I'll see what I can do.
Which team is hiding the bomb?
Man bomber?
Is this a trick question?
At chat!
The wolves inside us?
Okay.
Okay, it's wolves.
We're not cheating.
I'm just at chat.
Oh, incinerate.
There you go.
I have the guy.
Okay.
There we go, we did it.
I'm snacking mad doves today, baby.
Oh, thank God.
On Fuego.
Oh, God, there's so many.
Uh, we'll do vigor.
And then, God, there's so many people.
Hey, it's Rory Casey.
One of my teachers called out.
Guys, I don't have enough soup.
I have, I'm, we cut someone.
We cut someone, okay?
We have budget cuts, okay, guys?
Teach defense, assist with reflex.
There's been a talk about Koop's old crew being back in town.
Track down rumors.
Asserting the organization's target.
Shut your hole.
Everyone just relax.
I'm sure it's just a very unfortunate.
Oh, we are short-handed.
I can't believe it's a pay not good.
I thought the pay was good.
Toss, destroy the remains of Toss.
Oh, God.
We can handle this.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
97.
There's no way I lose this.
Alright, that's good.
Sick.
Okay, we gotta send one person at a time now.
Defense.
Drill.
Reflex.
God.
Fuck.
Okay.
Track that.
You got this.
You can track.
You go in by yourself.
I believe.
I'm a fucking loser that needs us that I'm on my way.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm gonna send Prism out here.
Okay, actually, uh, here, you got this, and then you go teach.
You have good reflexes.
You don't, but I don't have anyone else.
Actually, I can cut this close.
All right, you too.
Go teach.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Oh, oh, thank God, 65.
We made it.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Thank God.
This is why we didn't cut you.
I'll keep you around.
more than one reason uh mobility gotta make you super fast oh i forgot prism second i forgot her special ability okay really okay yeah no fucking shit you win some you lose some sometimes how is i supposed to know i need too okay but i think this is my last thought for the day is that good interesting we're not done for the day but someone's got to go check on coop oh thank god okay we just made it the baddest we just made it we were good teachers okay now we're super short oh dozens of youths just started
Wait.
Okay, wait.
He's a mind reader.
She has X-ray vision.
Together they are.
Send someone.
Okay, I think...
Oh, sorry.
Is this SDN?
We need help.
Okay, wait.
Obviously...
No, you're not doing this.
Alright.
She's fast.
You're training.
You know what?
Go do your thing.
I'm investing it all.
Wait, I had another one?
Oh my god, I already, but like, someone called us about a bomb in one of the theaters?
Oh my god, bro, okay, um...
Oh, no.
Protect the couple.
Send someone good at defusing situation.
Who is good at...
I assume Prism, right?
I think Prism can make it.
When in high breath, Sonar said he would talk his way out of it and re-attempt the car.
Sonar is immune and his resting...
Okay, yeah, we're gonna talk your way out of this.
Use that Harvard education you got.
All right.
Locate the bomb and disarm it.
Are you good at locating?
Maybe these two.
Yeah, they'll be fine.
Yeah, that's going to leave a mark.
There we go.
And then I can...
Oh, thank God.
Okay, you're healed.
I can wait a little bit.
I'm going to get Prism in here.
Oh?
Oh.
Which movie theater should we search first, guys?
Oh, is tracking intelligence?
Oh, we are so fucking stupid.
Oh, it's okay.
He can burn the bomb.
We can burn.
Chat.
Standing alive.
Okay.
Wow, guys.
What a lucky guess.
Oh.
I need punch.
He fucking left.
activate crawl through the vents guys we have zero intelligence which one is not the I feel like crawl crawl because I feel like activating requires IQ but we are three we're good at everything but IQ oh thank god oh thank god we just made it we're just fast enough that's how we do it down under ready okay we got prism Alright.
I'll put you two in here.
Robert, you were the last one to see my stapler.
What was I?
I don't think that's true.
You're the prime suspect.
Oh, come on!
Oh, oh, oh!
It doesn't matter!
Let's go!
We did it!
We detained the youths!
Yeah, fuck the children!
We tried to do it ourselves, but then I remembered my motto in life.
Why do it when you can make someone else do it for you?
Oh, you smart.
Okay.
Yeah.
That requires a brain.
Wait, we're doing, like, task rabbit here.
What?
No, Phil.
Can you just walk him around?
Walk Phil.
Phil is imposed hard.
God damn it.
Okay, we can wait a little.
That's fine.
Okay, we need someone strong.
Oh, disrupted.
Yeah, okay.
Mediate the argument.
Oh, I'll get to the bottom of this shit.
Alright, nice.
I'm glad there's no Grammy for this.
We did it.
Argument, mediated.
all right so it's time for phil's walk what there you go phil's my dog can you just like yeah around the park yeah he's like my dog yeah all right i feel like we could i can wait a little bit now put malin yeah this seems fine phenomena man still on the 405 all right he's gone from shaking his fist at cars to sadly directing traffic well at least he's putting his new phone uh get charisma i had no idea blazer was such a heartbreaker is that surprising i need vikes bigger i think she had dinner maybe you shouldn't be so quick to judge are you smart enough to rose you sound just like her we did it i knew you i knew going to harvard makes you able to read ikea instructions it's fine see i told you it's fine i got it all it's a like so too to walk a dog.
Robert, I found my stapler.
Where was it?
Immobility.
Actually, the combat.
And...
Yes, I can equalize Mal.
Uh, I'll put her, I'll make her more of a all-around person.
Hey, it's Jerry from Comic Pug.
We got a gift of some Mega Man replicas.
Yeah, but with all the bomb threats going on.
Suspicious Mega Man?
Mech, but with bomb threats.
I forgot what works with bomb threats.
Should we just go with bomb threats again?
Why?
Nothing beats the original, but...
It's fine, right?
We don't need...
We don't need vigor.
I think it's fine.
We got two in.
We're doing pretty good at the real part of the game.
We only had...
We fucked up one thing, and that was with Punch-Out, and now he's not there anymore.
Which mecha man contains the bomb?
What happens when we fuck up the choice?
It's like one out of three.
And this is a clean ass run.
Alright, at chat.
Let's do a lucky guess, guys.
This is all luck, by the way.
All luck.
Wow.
Who would...
Wow, guys.
We're so lucky.
How do we keep guessing the right mechas, chat?
Oh my god.
We're so smart.
We just somehow keep guessing the right ones.
We're like psychic or something.
And that's lunch.
They're so lucky.
Oh, great.
I'ma drink my spicy water.
All right, nice.
We only failed one.
That's fine.
Under review?
I haven't even been paid yet?
Like, what?
Oh, hey, a melon.
And chocolate?
Still working on that?
Aren't these the best?
I love the green ones the the green do oh the honey damn take the whole thing if you want awesome my lucky day I I know what's for lunch or dinner probably now sorry I uh interrupt bro if that bake has a nice ass my guy has his ass you feel my noodles away my initials were literally on the box and everything fuck I I don't read things sometimes it's different like a logo but it's probably still good I I don't What?
The fucking trash noodles?
Wet fart boy?
Whoa, what are you doing?
Whatever.
It was an accident.
Just aim your dick up and water piss it off.
That's not...
You...
To be fair, he wasn't being a really bad janitor, though.
How would you like to have to walk around work the rest of the day with shit all of you?
I don't know.
I don't think about that.
Because it won't happen.
Because I'm not a fucking idiot food thrower away here.
It was an accident.
You don't have to be a bully about it.
You want this in your report?
You're gonna snitch on me?
Wait, I can't even snitch on it.
I was being a soft bitch about it.
How am I being?
In fact!
Oh, wow.
I wasn't expecting it to go straight.
That was extra.
Sorry.
Spaghetti or spaghetti.
You're gonna choke on this fucking...
Hey, Robert, could you...
Spaghetti.
Did you eat my lunch?
Oh.
Why would you do that?
I don't want to be a snitch but flamb was really payback another hr report i don't even think they have hr well if you're gonna eat it i wish more of it got into your mouth go get cleaned up then clean this up then pick me up a blt from johnny's and we'll call it even yes what i'm saying is that like okay i feel like working hr for superheroes is like
Who's it going to be?
Phenomenon or Waterboy?
And these two are my only options.
For now, yeah.
Obviously, we can revisit it.
But Waterboy is already a trainee, sort of.
And you already know Phenomenon got cut by DTLA.
Thanks for getting him out of the parking lot, by the way.
It might also help to get, you know, an actual good person on your team, which...
Wait.
Are we cutting someone?
Like, if I pick someone, do I cut...
Put him on my team or joining my team.
Okay, I'm picking someone.
I am not picking Waterboy.
Guys, I...
There's no way.
If anything, Phenomena as act as a real fucking superhero.
Like, like, why?
I don't...
Bro.
Bro, Yes, I'd rather have a depressed Superman than someone that can't do anything.
It was at least a depressed Superman.
We don't need another healer.
Having another healer implies that I'd fuck up, but I don't fuck up.
Think of the potential.
Justice.
All right, we flip.
All right, we flip a coin.
Heads is water boy.
Tails is a phenomenon.
We're, we're, okay.
heads or tails heads or tails all right heads is water boy tails god fucking guys we got phenomenal we're not getting potential man guys we definitely got phenomenal man
ah okay okay how about this i'll make a poll i'll make a poll water water boy or potential man i don't know how to spell phenomenal potential the water boy bro okay i'll pick the one who bribes me the most jk never mind whoever i'm gonna use the bathroom and whoever bribes me the most gets to get some most bribes.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
We're accepting bribes now.
How else do you think people lobby shit in, in?
That's right.
We're lobbying.
I'm going to teach you what lobbying means.
I'll be right back, guys.
I go pee.
All right.
I'm back.
Okay.
He phenomenal man.
Water point lobby.
Water point bribe.
Now, thank you for the magenta super thank you thank you get potential man now i agree thank you magenta super super thank you super man super thank you thank you alan for uh thank you super chat thank you thank you face pumpkin thank you with super chat thank you thank you water boy lobby so very thank you with a super chat thank you thank you guys thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you when the building is crumbling the criminal shooting you don't want piss boy to rescue Vote Phenomenon for a brighter tomorrow Thank you for the Akka Super Thank you,
thank you Um, certified Ian, thank you for the magenta super Thank you, thank you Okay guys, has anyone been keeping count?
I don't know who's winning Water Okay, I think Waterboy is winning right now Joah, thank you for the magenta super Thank you, thank you All right, Waterboy is currently in the lead We have loved Waterboy is currently in the lead right now water boy you can't escape simple mind and think of a super chat thank you thank you i'm going to do a 10 second countdown and to see if a nomad man can come in uh and swoop in for the day all right 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 potential man right now for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
No Waterboy.
Oh, unfortunate Waterboy.
It looks like Phenoma man came in at the last second to lobby you up.
Sorry.
As I kindly take the donations for my campaign under the table, I have decided to go with potential man.
He has my vouch a natural i just thought naturally nobody influenced my decision um i would just took camp i just took campaign donations guys nothing was going on anyway i shall now lobby for potential man sleeping thank you for the magenta soup thank you thank you
I love democracy, guys.
Wait, Potential Man is?
Guys, okay, Greaves.
Wait, no, no, no.
Wait, Greaves donated before and with who he wanted.
Wait, he hasn't.
Greaves, all right.
Did you want it?
Greaves, did you want a Phenomenman or Waterboy?
Your donation changes the course of time.
I call both Potential Man, to be fair.
Are we, because Greece donation cements whether or not it's water boy or Phenomenon.
What did Greece say?
Yeah, water.
Is it, was it blue for water?
Greece, please.
It's a blue doorknob.
Is it blue for water, Greaves?
Water,
boy.
Blue for water.
I gotta be sure.
It's phenomenal.
Or is it his depression tears?
I gotta be sure.
Because your vote, your vote is the one that changes it all.
Blue.
He said it's phenomenal.
It's depression, man.
Guys, I don't know if you're fucking with me or if that's what he wants.
Guys, he said depression, man.
What if you're making that shit up?
It's depression, man.
I'm positive.
Both of them are.
Phenomenal, man, I guess.
I mean, I'm worried he has too much time to think right now.
That's...
Yeah, I feel the same way.
He could use a distraction.
So it won't be weird with your ex-boyfriend.
water boy i mean he's already hanging around so he may as well be doing some good instead of moping around the parking lot crushing cars now we phenomena has won the lobby i'll let him know you'll see him in the roster for your next dispatch why would i get mad it's okay he can drown his tears with work justice for water boy it's a fair and honest vote guys whoa a moment of your time how do you move so quiet the power of donations if it would make you more comfortable i could remove my clothes as well it would not look if this is about picking you for z team wasn't even a hard decision thank you no need see look at that but to do good you need to be doing i don't even watch you i just wanted to ruin the days of Waterboy!
Like a true village.
Oh, shit.
I'm going to have reopened your chest wounds.
He's thinking of a super chat thing.
Thank you.
Waterboy tried lobbying first.
He just wanted to see the world suffer.
Where is he?
Where's potential, man?
Hey, team.
We appreciate you doing your best.
Last shift under the sun.
circumstances but we are here to help more specifically phenomenal here to help there he is here to help he's gonna be here to help whoops that he's gonna be here to help guys everything would be fine this guy didn't he also get fired yeah listen i know things have been difficult for him no he got relocated guys a great addition to the team difficult because he dumped him Damn.
Don't like me.
The mean child is correct.
Wait, I think, no, I'm glad we picked Phenomenal.
The opportunity to see her again will make every day easier.
I think you gotta be backwards, bro.
Yeah, it don't work that way, boy.
Trust me.
Oh, you're so depressed.
It's great.
We have reason to believe that Mr. Vanderstank's life will be in danger out of me.
You know what?
I got you.
Really want me?
Yeah.
I got you, bro.
Go in there.
You...
No, I didn't just get ditched.
Apologies.
What?
I thought I saw a blonde blazer in distress.
Phenomenal man.
I'm at the office.
These one-on-one scenery, I think I can make this a regular thing.
Oh, who should get it?
You know what?
I'll put you in.
Wait, don't worry.
He's coming in to help out.
Wait, did he help out?
Wait, he did it.
Wait, where was he?
Hey, so we're a little down on new subscribers this month.
I think you can spare here.
Cheerful, positive attitude.
Budget cuts.
Well, then how the fuck are we supposed to do this?
You could try charming them with your winning personality.
Oh, wait, we have charisma here.
Yeah, there you go.
Wait, who has more charisma?
Yeah, he has most charisma.
That's why we have a clone.
What's this?
After also creates a portal, near the call also reveals the stats the next call she's assigned to okay we should do that that's fine it's okay we had his clone we don't need him we have the clone guys oh my god okay that's fine that's why no we did it guys it's okay we have the clone van der stank lives to innovate another day see look he did his job technically
Yeah, the clone wasn't depressed.
I just gotta pair him up with a quick prism.
Send a charming and good-looking hero.
Physicality is valued in addition to looks.
I mean...
Phenomenal?
Do they like depressed?
Are they okay with depressed men?
Like...
I'm just... I'm wondering if he's depressed.
Is that okay?
Like, like, some women will want to fix him, right?
Like, that can work.
More charisma.
Okay.
Let's see.
On it.
I don't know.
Who's more?
Who's, who's Mel or Blam Bay?
Yeah, he does have Blam Bay in there.
Okay, let's grab combat too.
No, I don't think Punchy's gonna do it.
Prism?
Mal?
I feel like Waterboy had all the charisma.
Oh.
Okay, charming.
I think, like, Mal.
I mean, look at Mal.
What would your job be?
I feel like working at a gas station would be pretty chill.
Nice, we got it.
I'm not going to the pet store.
Yeah, right.
You hate pets.
I hate pets with bad attitudes.
What pets have good attitudes?
Snakes?
I guess so.
They're just chill.
Every snake is chill.
You just sit there.
Speaking of pets, I have recently learned of the American opossum.
I find it fascinating how it carries its children's heart.
Okay, sure.
Much like a bus.
What the fuck is he talking about?
Yeah, what the fuck is he talking about?
Possums aren't pets, man.
I see.
That's not true.
You can technically any animal can pee.
No, actually, don't do not.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, don't.
Don't quote me on that.
Don't quote me that.
I'm not in for exotic animals, guys.
Not all pets.
Guys, not all pets can be...
Not all animals can be pets, guys.
Not all animals can be pets.
Guys, I don't want to get in trouble.
They fight the mascot during halftime.
Make it look convincing, but pull your punches.
Maybe these two?
Do I need intelligence for that?
Like, do I gotta make it look smart?
I wasn't sure about it either.
I don't know about it.
You're trying to tell me something.
But...
I don't know.
Groovy.
I don't know if you need intelligence for that.
You need combat.
Yeah, I feel like I need...
You know what, I'll put Kodam in here.
I can do it.
I don't know.
Depends on the dirt.
Oh, packing time.
Ah, you lucky bastard.
Hacked into the computer?
Oh, it's no difficulty.
I got this.
That's for babies.
Look at that.
What's this?
Okay, I gotta get a key for that.
Oh.
Oh, wait, I'm timed.
Oh, I was not paying attention.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, um...
Oh, this is hard.
Okay, we got this.
Right, right, down.
Okay, right, right, down.
Okay.
Right, right, down.
Oh, what?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, oh, they said it was low!
Right, right, down.
Okay.
I gotta block him off?
Oh, no!
Okay, last chance.
Right, right, down.
Like that?
Oh!
Okay.
And then I could do this.
Right, right, down.
Right, right.
Okay, guys, remember, look at this.
Okay, give me the right password.
What's the right password?
Guys, I...
Did it?
Right, right, down.
Left, left, up.
What?
Right, right, down.
Wait, left, left, up.
Oh.
Left, left, up.
Right, right, down.
Okay.
Oh, God, this is not good.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you get past her security we i couldn't get past her security these are two sides no why are you depressed i should be depressed my outside was always so strong okay that's fine sure fine that's fine a symmetrical stage picture robert i am sensing dissatisfaction amongst my new companions I don't fucking go.
I was stating the super obvious.
You did one job.
No wonder Blazer.
This is what happened.
You said you wanted help.
I got you one of the best heroes at SDN.
The best at pissing everyone off.
Yeah, yeah.
The best at crying.
The best at leaving a giant crater.
Guys, stop.
He won't keep himself safe.
Stop.
He needs to keep himself safe, guys.
I captured a small, it may be a little, but it's so strong.
strong um i think golden can do it new me fucking rocks nice i'll put both of you guys in there
okay nice 100.
i'm stacking mad dugs today baby i knew we got this but convince the boss if all fails okay oh you're not smart okay charisma Wait, actually, maybe?
He's returning?
Hello, dispatcher.
Hello?
What kind of game?
A brain teaser.
I hate this asshole.
Careful.
Oh, adopted.
His name is Brain Teaser.
How tricky can he be?
Oh my god, he's my Riddler.
That's a baby right there.
I know what I gotta do.
Oh, shit.
You got a new pet.
A new child.
Riddler's meeting him.
this batman i will make her an all-arounder
find the brain humor let's humor him answer my riddle god damn it one two three and i will gladly turn myself in a wise investment okay okay so the thing is look i know that he but he has another chance he he okay look at guys the thing is if he fucks up he has another chance to do it again guys that's the thing he try the other option what's the other option i could also just track you down oh it only works in okay okay
wait but i want to do his riddle
guys but i want to do his riddle though not start a war here with an elite assassin organization convince your boss you know what we'll send him these two oh wait we shouldn't we'll send in these here you know do you because then they'll have send prism i don't know if i can okay i want to do the riddle but some buddies who live under okay i have time and before you ask yes withstand the beer bottles.
Okay, we have nothing.
It's okay, I have this.
Alright, we actually, we can...
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
We can wait a little bit.
Alright.
Okay, but we don't have enough intelligence, though.
That's the thing.
Wait, okay, he's gonna do this?
And then I'm gonna...
I'm gonna give it to the bat.
There we go.
I just wanna wait for him to return.
This is fine.
Oh, my gosh.
This is still fine.
No.
We invested it all on one guy.
That's fine.
All right.
And then he returns.
Half-batt all freak.
He's going to return.
And he's going to be teaser me this.
There you go.
Go do your thing.
I need to find my...
Do your riddle.
It was standing up beer bottles.
Cheer up and persuade.
Okay, we can just do this.
these here.
Oh, he's back.
He's not depressed anymore.
Intercom malfunctioning.
Can anyone hear me?
All right, more intelligence.
All right, there we go.
I believe in depressed, the Phenomenon.
Okay, let's start.
What is my favorite game?
The Wolf Within Us?
I don't know, fucking old-brainy 1949.
The wolves have eyes.
The wolves inside us.
Is it the wolves within us?
That's like the wolves among us, right?
Or the wolves inside us.
Inside us?
That's a... Okay.
Oh, oh, it's the same.
What about my... Oh, it's standing alive, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Standing alive, right?
Yeah, it's the bombs.
I remember the bombs.
Make a man prime.
I remember this.
There you go.
Yeah, okay, maybe I...
Okay, anybody.
Jesus Christ!
Come and get me.
I've been waiting downstairs in the lobby for at least 30 minutes.
What the fuck is wrong with your head?
There's no skull!
He has no skull!
It's just brain!
Time to freak some fuckers out.
Alright.
More intelligence!
Actually, I don't think I need more intelligence, actually.
I think we can chill a bit on that.
I think we can chill a little bit.
Maybe more intelligence is not the best thing.
You know what?
Let's give you intelligence.
You're my all around it.
He was the brain teaser.
Are you aware your entire head is just brain?
Like, you fucking squish the top of his head and he's dead.
Like, actually.
Like, he bumps his head and his fucking entire head.
brain bleeds he goes into a coma I'm actually making Batman are you okay that's scary I was gonna okay I know y'all saw that don't be jealous it's okay it's okay all right nice oh I didn't really oh nice just one that's the hacking one but we don't need to worry about that yeah I got here another injury oh my I swear to God,
it was another...
It was another one.
Ooh, it's good with mobility.
I will put it...
We'll put...
We'll give it to her.
All in.
All in on her, because she wants to bang me.
I do have favorites.
Whoever is the most horny for me.
I was going to say sad sack, son of a bitch.
But, yeah, let's go with yours.
Yeah, let's go with mine Hey kid Love you Whoa Love you too, aren't you?
Don't fuck this up
Oh, is that my dad?
My photos of my dad?
That's how to get that's right You want a promotion?
That's definitely an HR violation
Oh, there you go is jesus christ every time i see him he's so oh my god bro hey mom hey honey he is he is like a he's an absolute unit by that measure there's an 800k way tie for first thank you for the super chat listening thank you thank you
oh my god he's finally getting his first extra Same.
It's like, what you want me to do?
Run?
Fucking it, loser.
Crazy.
Fucking crazy.
Oh, it's depression, man.
Also, do they even do superhero stuff anymore?
I swear she just does office work instead.
Earlier that day, Blazer and I had at the rim of an active volcano then we made love I don't need to hear your sex stories we never had intercourse my alien genitals were not too tired of it it's uh it's not what were you saying she was the only thing I was passionate about her voice her eyes I know why they broke up her whole of her How do you know?
How do you know she's the only thing you're passionate about if you haven't found anything else you're passionate about?
Your logic with that statement.
You have to laugh.
No, no, what is she dubbed it, bro?
What you need to do is find the next thing for you to be passionate about.
Because it's out there.
Thank you.
I wish to make a love to you again.
Again.
Oh, is that?
Oh, this time I will avoid squeezing the blood out.
Wait, what?
That's how he fought?
Bro!
Oh, okay.
I did not realize hugging was his form of intercourse.
What you watching?
Technically, you're still on the clock.
Another HR violation right there.
On the clock, you shouldn't be pegging me with anything, Robert.
especially since I'm usually the picker not the peg oh he's definitely a hugger well tell me how it is these ESL turkey don't make fun of him I always forget what I'm watching by the time the movie starts same you going solo I'm a loner Robbie a rebel that night feel bad asking people to pay when I'm just gonna sneak in the only lame thing is I can't get snacks floating buckets of popcorn too tend to draw a lot of attention but I miss it I miss popcorn Just get popcorn.
Just go and go to the theater.
Oh, shit.
Bro, don't do this to me.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Do I want a bad bitch?
Oh, bro.
Oh.
Do you want a bad bitch or a muscle mommy?
That's so hard to pick, man.
The thing is Invisigal Or Visi already Showed us what she can do But we haven't seen what Blazer could do guys That's the thing Like
Top boy Like the thing is But we haven't They haven't shown us what she could do We saw what the other girl could do Like Fair.
Like, we haven't been shown everything.
Musa, mommy, no question.
So sad.
I'm thinking with a super chat.
Don't be greedy.
But, but like, but I love being greedy.
Go with your heart.
Oh, you know, you know what.
I won if I go with my heart because I'm a greedy girl.
I'm a greedy bitch.
I won it all.
You know it.
All right.
Time to solicit the folks.
Pick neither.
They're both red flags.
BL, they even super chat.
Thank you.
People who think click blazer to see people who think salt is spicy.
But we don't even know if she's freaky.
You don't know that.
You don't even know if she's freaky or not.
She never even had, she never even had the mecha man though, you guys, come on, how long has he been, she's been dating depression man, bro, you know she's gonna be wild.
You be wild.
Only got muscle, dragon, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Greaves, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
the world burn how much money do you need for me to make you pick blazer thank you for this super chat thank you thank you glaze the blaze you know what we'll do we'll we'll do the polls we'll actually do a poll this time all right and screw it i'm putting my money where the peg is it's busy time all right you can't blame me whoever wins wins you can't who muscle Bad.
I'll let the people vote.
Oh.
Wait, it's close.
It's so close.
All right.
To the muscle enjoyers.
Why?
Give your case.
Come on, Blaze.
Blaze is better than no big six-inger.
Convince your people!
Convince your people, why?
She got no Blaze.
Because of muscle.
Do we even need to explain it?
All I'm saying, guys, all I'm saying is that bro, she has been dating.
depression man for how long and like they never were able to do anything so you know she freaky she she freaky pia nigga with super chat thank you thank you chat muscle dump the sweetheart phenomenon desert thank you with super chat thank you thank you thank you thank you i don't have a case but it wouldn't be funny thank you super chat thank you thank you you all know you all know why we choose here patrice thank you super chat thank you thank you i'm not trying to have a power dynamic when woman who needs a mentor not someone trying to use it i'm trying to have woman put the power dynamic on me desire thank you super chat thank you thank you uh i'm i snored a lime and wasabi for a night between
Madwick, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Don't keep, blonde blazer in comics needs Robert, trust, go with blonde blazer.
Guide to the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Tomboy is Tomboy.
Do I date my boss or date the person I'm in charge of?
Oh my, okay, this is like really bad, don't bad in real life, but like, do I date?
Guys, but if I date my boss.
there's a more likely of a chance i get a promotion i the you're true true the bad girl does have um does have more baggage the power dynamic is crazy both ways both ways i'm just saying one of those girls can fold you in half and you know what each one that is not dressed to think of a super chat And she's going to make you go out in a blaze of glory.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Invisi, not the best.
PL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cut and visi, girl.
And then date her 100%.
God damn it, guys.
Get that promotion, queen.
Thank you for the magenta sofa.
Thank you.
Ah, this is so hard.
This is the highest decision of my life.
That's why I'm letting you guys decide.
Because whatever happens, you guys, if you guys fuck it up, then it's not my fault.
All right, I will leave the poll up for two more minutes so you guys better campaign for the indecisive voters.
You guys better shout your case for the indecisive voters right there.
They're the ones that matter.
They're the ones that will change the tide for all of you.
We already got the pull.
All right.
I'm going to do a countdown, guys.
I should know.
I'm going to wait till it hits five.
When it hits five minutes, everyone.
Then.
Then I'll pick.
Missy again.
Rise up.
Guys, please.
Tomboy.
HR violation usually go upwards.
Ollie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I thank you for the five gift of ships.
Vote Gorilla Grip Vote Vlad Blazer Let's see, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Zonderman Thank you, thank you, thank you Tomboy, how is that even a Question Oh my gosh, these are such Hard decisions in life I'm glad I don't have to make this decision I do think The Muscle Mommy and Joyers Are more vocal I think the bad bitch,
the tomboy, the tomboy lovers are like the silent majority.
They are like the silent majority right there.
They might not talk as much.
But they will come out and vote when needed.
All right.
It's five minutes.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Muscle enjoys.
I know.
I know how much you wish we could...
You wish you could get bent in half by her.
But...
Oh my god, I almost pressed her on.
But it looks like...
It looks like we're going with the tomboy.
I didn't see the first one.
Can you give me a recap?
watching like this actually it's illegal for you to be filming i don't need the whole thing just enough to know what's going on okay it's about this struggling actress who gets this big role from a movie star and a mistake the track loads can't be bought democracy one thank you for the super chat parent thank you then he realizes her secret but it turns out he has a secret too which could ruin.
Oh, shit.
There's sour patch.
Hey.
You didn't hear any of that?
Yeah.
No.
It's probably fine, though.
So, what are we, like, friends now?
Or is this some sort of team-building exercise?
I thought we already were.
To be fair, I thought we already were.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Oh.
Would have been nice to know.
before I spend 86 bucks.
I'm not gonna fuck you just because you bought me a bucket of corn.
Who said I was gonna fuck you?
Can you just be normal for like a second?
I just bought popcorn.
I just must have bought me for you.
This is nice.
What are you gonna say?
Do you like sour patch kids?
I didn't choose wrong.
She laughed.
Sour patch kids.
Look at that.
Whoa, look at that.
Didn't fuck it up.
me too i'm in also yeah yeah no i'm not surprised it's a movie theater they fucking gaucho's purchase i'm surprised it wasn't a hundred bucks
ah man i didn't up that decision i knew i didn't it up all right you and 487 38% of players oh my god the majority added water for I have a people oh man I guess tomboy lovers were the majority
you and Warren you and 35% of players confessed to kissing blonde blazer I'm right I did you and 20% saved all three businesses yeah I did it oh wait I'm so smart you and 25% players correctly answered all three I did it okay Toki I regret my vote can you go back to muscle mommy thank you for the super chat BL thank you thank you oh shit wait I fucking nailed this one you performed better at 10% players right nailed it you will carry the weight of your decision
You knew what you...
You have to carry this way for the rest of your life.
Ah, I don't know if I should do another episode.
I'm having fun.
Oh, my God.
No, I nailed it.
Look at this.
You performed...
Oh.
All right, one more.
I'll do one more.
I'll do one more up.
I'm having fun.
Oh, is that the bitch you block forever?
Okay, okay, I'm gonna- I won't end it with that.
I'm- I'm content with ending it with that one.
That's everybody.
All clear.
It's eight episodes.
One name I will show you how to read.
I think it's very far from now.
Mr. McPublican, so you will see for chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, shit.
I'm a fast-ass runner.
Why am I not buff for all the exercise I do?
Damage is done.
Oh No need to do any more.
Oh, oh flamb
Was it all cardio?
Oh, that's true.
He was in a coma forgot about that There's a code of a famous v2 or something my asian map and bananas guys.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Matt, thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Now he's doing like...
Now he's putting on... doing muscle gain stuff.
The 165 with that frame?
Bro, he doesn't even have a spotter.
He's so... he's so fucking stupid.
And this is how you fucking break your chest.
Yeah, he's like benching solo.
You're not supposed to live without a spa.
You do not have superpowers.
You weak.
Now I'm getting a safety lecture from a walking fireball.
It's a reality check.
Normies need babysitters so you don't hurt yourself thinking you're a hero.
Man, I am so fucking strong.
I'm not a normal.
I'm not normie.
I watch anime.
I see a fucking wet white boy put up more on the bench.
No more hero stuff without supervision.
You can't get injured.
Because we need you behind that desk to help real heroes.
Uh, actually speaking of injuries, remind me, who took your tooth?
Um.
It's like they only stole that little bit.
I got to do a fight with an actual real actual hero.
And I assure you, he's real.
regretting his decision to tangle with me.
I'm into Gundam, okay?
Bro, this is how he gets his ass.
And you, it's time for you to accept it.
You don't got it anymore.
And pretending you still do is bombing people the fuck out.
Now, get your flat ass off my bench.
This is so true.
Bro, his ass is so fucking flat.
You know, this squad like that bay.
Many.
Oh.
Aw, look, he got me a gift.
Bro, it's that bad.
Bro, you know, you know, he's been squatting for another reason.
Like, that ass can, like, that ass got kicked.
Oh, treats are work.
Damn.
Already?
Oh, you ever noticed the Torrance vibe is, like, rancid?
Between the dead fish in the harbor and the giant refinery, it can't tell who's to blame.
Dang, that's some nasty.
Man, I love the smell of the refinery.
I hate the smell of gasoline.
I love the smell of gasoline.
Yeah, we going in.
We're clocking in for my 9 to 5.
Who pissed in your cereal?
Now that's some nasty shit.
Let's do this.
Alright, we sent Depression Man in first.
Torrance Middle School needs judges for our annual talent show.
Do it for the kids.
okay i got i'm sitting prism in i can't trust you actually no we're gonna find three slots so magnetic personality charlie and it's good with kids i think charlie can handle it it doesn't need anything else do you ever feel like you had so much potential and you're being wasted as a cog in a corporate machine do not send crypto bro in I'm gonna teach the kids crypto All right,
this is it There we go, depression man There you go I believe Is this man familiar with See, alright, there we go, there you go Depression man, he's gonna do it I think Charlie is very good With kids He's a business genius Everything he does is brilliant There you go,
see, let's go It's no crypto now.
Jesus, kid.
Let's go.
Isn't this like the third time one of his projects has fallen apart?
But speed is key.
Oh, okay.
We're like...
We're literally maxed out on speed.
There's no way.
Yeah, I was gonna say, we're 10.
Too bad there's no Grammy for this.
You monster.
Oh, it's...
What's this?
The parents started fighting over the results and then the kids joined in too.
Convince them non-violently, please.
Okay.
Ah, no, I don't have charisma.
I can wait a little bit.
They're resting.
It's fine.
Oh, it's this.
SDN's tolerable and inclusive workplace make you a great sponsor for our aliens and mummies exhibit.
This looks like a job for Phenomenon.
Who is me?
Yeah, but you don't, you don't look like an alien.
I'm going to send in.
I'm going to send in man bat.
Oh, shit.
He's a natural bat right now.
Okay, that's fine.
Training time.
Oh, send in.
That's true.
It's training time if anyone's up for it.
Yeah, but he doesn't.
What if he doesn't show up?
Guys, what if he doesn't show up?
up yeah i got a coupon for a free all right i'm sending it but if he doesn't show up for the kids i swear to god so don't tell her nothing i remember my first talent punch up creates a slot exclusively for him to join second place impossible i'm gonna stop car okay we'll do that i got her back though i shot a laser beam and burned all that hair off so i guess you're the real winner Sure am.
Inspired my- Oh, wait.
Tell them about- Oh, wait, there you go.
Oh, my God, it worked.
Sounds like a real bop.
Never say bop again.
Look at that.
See?
Not so depressing now.
Is it?
Look at that.
Can't be that bad.
I, dear Drazy, yes, that, dear Drazy, need help to make him disappear.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't have smart people in my team.
I don't know why.
I think I only have one person in my team that's smart.
Oh, this is so bad.
Are you fucking?
Okay, thank God.
I wonder why.
Why did I go all in on the Harvard graduate?
Is anyone smart?
Three, three, three.
Okay.
Okay, maybe.
Okay, we're sending in.
I'm trying to increase this.
God, I'm going to increase.
her intellect and then I'm gonna fix it.
Torrents Middle School is hosting an anti-bullying seminar and it would mean a lot.
Oh my god, why are they...
...and their parents.
So you don't matter.
Okay.
Together, the two of us will be unstoppable.
Okay, it's fine.
I bet you say that to everybody.
It's fine.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna give coffee.
Feeling fresh.
Her and then...
Um...
I
Think this will work.
You know what?
Perfect as always.
Let's put them together I'm on my way.
I know like maybe he'll and quick man back with sonar is gonna scare people, but that's okay Miss a rabies shot or something power was out at my place couldn't even check up on my investments.
Oh, no The numbers that go up and down every day.
You'll be fine Survey restraining order Okay, do you think I can delete all the files in time?
I think I can do it.
I doubt Deidre is the only victim of this.
Let's delete all the files on his laptop.
I believe in myself.
Get the backups too.
And the backups too.
Okay.
Right, right, left.
What?
Guys, what is...
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, it's fine.
Left, left, right.
Left, left, right, left, left, right, left, left, right, left, left, right, left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Left, left, left, left.
left left left right left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left left
left left left left left left left left left left left left right left right
right left right right right left right right right left right right right right
right there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go there you go i was panicking i was panicking i was panicking all right yay was this that hard jesus i deleted it all from the cloud wasn't even that Oh,
that was close.
My might is your might.
So easy.
The set needs a background actor for an upcoming scene.
The last one stormed off in a hurry.
Break a leg, but not like that.
Okay, we need charisma.
I guess hair.
This is fun.
Oh, wait, oh, wait, oh, wait.
We did it, guys.
It wasn't even that hard.
Hey, we're getting flooded with calls about suing in a couple neighborhoods.
where should we hit first okay wait i couldn't get her in bam here we go sewage spill there's poop the sewage is spilling out venturing into the sewage repair that broke with sand the sheer force i feel like if it's withstanding then like here yeah you could go in there phenomena man is probably the most bullyable on z team now i am often bullied for my There we go.
See, look at how much work he's doing.
Phenomenon.
Look at Phenomenon, girl.
Every compliment is a reminder that I am disgusting.
Oh, God, that was so close.
You look great.
Roberts is bullying me.
Please ask him to stop.
What the fuck did I do?
I'm fucking trying to cure your goddamn depression.
Are you?
Oh, that's close.
all right 97 nice we saved the beach hope this makes it a little easier yay beach has been saved all right i'm gonna put more intelligence onto my people like i we can't rely on charlie what i found out was relying on charlie on the iq test might be specific type of hero for my someone unassumably strong?
Oh, um.
Oh, man.
That's okay.
Give me a sec.
Maybe Gollum?
I think Gollum.
Gollum?
He's...
Yeah, but he's not that strong, guys.
He has a three.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
My rejected TEDx San Antonio talk will finally get the Recognition it deserves Sometimes reaching a certain point Will have an effect like this one Which will guarantee a fail Here?
Your team will fail this scenario?
Wait, what?
Mysterious fire is broken out at the refinery We got it under control But we can't investigate the cause with all these dangerous fumes Flamb I would never blow up a refinery, okay?
They smell like shit will fail oh okay so no combat oh that's hard oh hell yes oh this is bad me really okay Oh, this is bad.
Um...
I'm your guy.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I've messed up.
I think if I send in...
Oh.
I'm a little bit too combat-oriented.
I guess I send in my all-rounder.
I have to send in my all-rounder.
there oh we're done a good job though
do i send in do i send in golem or malvola we're not sending phenomena man golem or melvona which is better all
right i'll send in golem buildings would randomly blow up oh man more than the hallways is oh golem in last oh i forgot about that i forgot about golem in last lot look if you wanted to grab dinner all you had to do is ask are you oh my no no no oh god oh god okay you're not my type i forgot about the slides this thing you've ever said to me that's okay i think golem can solo this all right i don't learn my lesson i don't learn my lesson i keep putting him in okay we got okay now we can't keep putting on combat okay mobility i think he's smart enough
all right golem i believe you got this Oh, God.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh,
oh.
Oh.
Something about this feels off.
We're so close.
That was so close.
You did not guide.
It was rigged from the start.
Oh, my God.
time we've seen beef he gets food maybe he's got an iron stomach do we know anybody like that super digestion the gluttony but oh they're trying to figure out who the superhero is a thousand pounds hey robert did you recently lose like 700 pounds first off you're either at math or you think i'm like 300 pounds i am not i go to the gym and i work hard secondly what are you talking about there's a pool going around on which superhero this does not sound like aaron paul at all
He sounds so serious, so mature.
Could be house.
Just one hint.
I mean, we're friends, right?
I was blue.
What if he was blue?
What does that mean?
Wait, we sad?
Yes, but that was just a coincidence.
Oh, come on, don't be like that.
Sorry, you're just gonna have to earn $936 in some other way.
What way could that be?
I'll let you know if I work it out.
Did it?
I'm explaining the joke.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Decent reflexes?
Hey, beef!
No!
No, no coffee!
Do you know that talk too much and have quick reflexes?
Clean this shit up.
Hey, losing all that weight don't make you better than us!
Hey, yeah!
Shut up, Dad.
I never had a dad.
Aw.
I know.
Fuck that's supposed to me.
I mean...
Told me one time you didn't have a dad.
Huh.
I mean, it's sort of obvious a little.
She definitely looks like she has daddy issues.
heard the team scuffling with the red ring they run half the crime in the county we were bound to bother them at some point watch yourself you poke the hive you're gonna have to fuck the queen that's not how bees work you know what i mean i don't actually no one's trying to fuck shroud yeah he's a taken man you would do that kill shroud yes you might get the chance you don't want to go in there having to think about it No hesitation.
Shroud killed him, Chase.
There's only one thing I can do.
You know that's not true.
I'm not sure your dad would want it that way.
You're not sure.
Should we ask him?
Should we ask a dead man that died to him?
I know Batman!
Mecha man's coming back to life one patch at a time.
One patch at a time.
I mean, Roy's doing most of the work, though, right?
So much.
this shit yeah heroes do kill the good ones so maybe if we maybe because we kept letting these villains go we keep having so much crime folks welcome back we got a few guests actually like leading one right now is blue balls man actually like for this business model we shouldn't be killing villains i understand let me we have to let just let them go just so We can have more subscribers.
Yes, his power is not being able to nut.
Nah, his balls are literally blue, dude.
Get your head out of the gutter.
Great.
Oh, he's sick.
Why is Goldham sick?
Yeah, I'll be out of business if I keep killing villains.
Mr. Kat is all there.
It's so scary.
So please find my boy.
Because a known escape I was in very fast.
He hates most people.
Okay, I have fast here.
I'll put two.
Okay.
What?
Did we just lose power?
What's the fuck?
What happened?
Citywide, hang tight.
We're booting up the backup generator.
There we go.
Hey, Robert.
Just brace yourself.
What?
Why?
Oh.
There's going to be a lot.
A lot of people are going to ask for help now.
close your eyes before yeah same i mean i can see in the dark so this is pretty standard for me all right you guys the whole city's out guys this is an all hands-on situation okay i'm gonna get a grid back up and running be ready oh there's gonna be a lot of stuff yeah there's gonna be a lot of people some real action oh okay lots of hacking now restart the power okay it says low difficulty but last time someone tricked me about that Okay,
I'm not timed, though, which is good.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I'm, like, funneling energy back to people.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
Oh, this is smart.
Okay, I think I have to do this one.
Okay, and then I grab energy here.
Oh, I like this.
This is a neat concept.
And then I funnel energy here.
And I grab energy here.
Mr. Hacker Man.
And then...
Bam!
There you go.
That's an easy one.
Yeah, I like how there's a lot of variety in these hacking games.
Yeah.
I've lost contact with the tower and it's pitch black out here.
I cannot land this thing help Oh, don't worry.
It's the plane on the ground Sounds dangerous.
I got flyers.
You guys can handle it.
Oh Oh Oh, never mind.
I don't got flyers
You're hurt, but oh yeah, you're you're so hurt wait actually I got you
You know what?
What?
All in.
Also healing.
What's a hell of a deal?
It's fine.
We don't need flyers.
They cannot fly.
And yet they are- Oh, there was a choice?
It's fine.
Drang fucking slaps.
Can you blame them for Drang?
But their feeble bodies were meant for gentler activities, such as walking and- Uh-oh.
I knew it.
There you go.
Open pointer.
Yeah, exactly.
I told you guys.
The danger.
I don't need no flyers.
I suppose their futile efforts to become more than they are is admirable.
Okay, my mother lives in the senior community.
She hasn't answered the phone.
Go door.
Be sure to be prepared to provide medical assistance.
I think she can do that.
Wait, okay.
What?
Oh, I don't know.
I'll think about it.
Actually, I think...
My mother lives in the Parkwood senior community.
And she hasn't answered her phone.
There we go.
All around there.
Love me.
Yeah, I know the elderly love you.
Your depression!
They see you and they'll be less depressed.
Can you lend a hand?
Preferably a stronger.
Any delays will cause another explosion?
Oh shit.
Oh god.
Okay, we'll think about that later.
Hello.
My baby brother ate my mommy and dad.
Huh?
baby rescue the parents out of the oh okay I need all of that okay huh okay we're gonna rest a little bit don't worry we have time to figure this out oh my Oh my god, why did I go all- it's fine.
I believe in her.
Mostly, like, bad shit, though.
God damn it.
The red ring stealing shipments right off the train.
We're not equipped to stop them.
Red ring?
Fuck him up.
We just gotta do all- okay, I can't- I have an idea.
Go there!
Oh.
What's it gonna be this time?
Okay, her.
I'll crack some skulls.
Yeah, it's fine.
Like, dark and shit out here.
Uh.
Uh, okay, we'll see what we get here.
Nice.
I knew it.
I've always believed.
Okay.
Secure defeat the red goons.
Okay, depression, man.
Mal.
I know a secret.
What?
Would you kind of keep it?
Oh, shit.
Wait, yeah.
Let's go.
I don't need to keep a secret.
Alright.
Strangely, that's not the first time I've heard that.
Alright, at least the hacking is not timed this time, for real.
I think I use my brain.
Alright, here.
We'll grab the passcode.
Alright, guys.
Remember this passcode.
Up, down, up, left, right.
Up left, right.
Okay, and then put it here.
And then grab this.
There you go.
Got a double.
Up left, right.
There you go.
Easy.
God, I'm such a good hacker, man.
No, you killed him.
Then you were just same villain being seen in medieval thank you for the super chat oh oh i made it nice yeah i knew it see golem why can't you do that golem why could you do that vandals are defacing the torrents library mural hurry and catch them before there are peens everywhere stop the catch the preteens okay he's fast right not the penises it's a house of knowledge calm me angry okay oh god oh no that's bad
okay all right that's good i was gonna say thank god all right we might be oh we might be a little fucked here because we don't have enough intelligent people in the team so I'll put intellect in golem so I'm looting the Ralph's you want anything I was about that I needed to coffee I was trying to get coffee nice
I'm so sad
oh oh that's awkward oh that's so awkward
I will grab charisma I don't think we need more right nah we can grab charisma And then we'll also grab charisma here, too.
We've got a situation at Ben Labs.
They told me to call SDN.
I'm just an intern.
Oh.
Bro, my all of them are so strong.
They're all.
I must excuse myself.
They're depressed again?
Again.
Okay, who's the least...
strongest i guess golem i think golem is the only one i could do okay we're gonna have to do golem i'm heading downtown see you can use some help feel free to send someone i work better alone all right he's actually the only one
okay do we act quickly Okay.
Mobility.
Alright, we got that.
Oh, no.
Why don't we have backup generator city?
What's the taxpayers' money for?
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, did I destroy it?
Oh!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Zap zap!
Nearly there.
Okay.
Let's just go.
Okay, we gotta do this.
All right, it shocked him.
Zap zap!
All right.
I don't need a wait.
What did you do?
Is that XP or whatever can reveal number of slots and crime types on hover for certain cause before they happen?
No, I'll just grab the double XP.
I think double XP seems a lot better.
We've got several looting's in progress and our guys are getting overwhelmed.
Looting?
I had a team in...
Oh, basic.
Assisting and evacuating.
I'm robbing banks.
originality Shut up.
It's like the go-to blackout activity and besides burning all those shitty candles your aunties.
I don't know what apprehend the thieves Do I need to be fast?
I was thinking I'll just be fast unless We could double yeah, you know what?
All right, that's five Jesus Christ
Oh, yeah, fuck me I guess okay chair.
Yeah, man.
I got a bad headache right now.
It's that's why it's I was a little bit.
Why did it send intelligence?
I'll take care of it.
There we go.
There's no way I need any intellect for this.
There's no way.
Can I at least keep the guys responsible?
There's no way I need any brains for this.
I swear to God.
Oh, God.
Come on.
Sonar.
And Phenomenal, I'm sorry.
It was fucking depressed.
I'm fighting him.
I have 10.
You don't even need to say it.
Fuck these guys up.
There's no way.
I was gonna say, I have 10.
I went all in on combat.
Yeah, I'm making you an all-rounder.
I have too many stupid people on my team.
I can't rely all on him because sometimes he changes to a dumb guy.
Search and rescue.
I don't know what search and rescue would be.
That's the thing.
Okay, thank God.
10, 10, 10.
You sure we don't work on commission?
Wait for Mel?
She's slowly returning.
Oh, there's so many people.
My daughter was at the beach with her friends.
And I haven't heard from her.
I'm really worried.
Uh...
We'll do him.
You are quite an intimidating specimen.
Oh, God.
Okay.
On the outside.
Sobred on the inside.
I believe that is how all life forms are.
Yeah, I meant like metaphorical.
I messed up.
A metaphorical dog.
Where?
Fresh as a daisy.
You don't need to see shit to punch shit.
Oh.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
I'm putting more intelligence in here.
I need more smart people on my team.
It's fine.
Those fences are at it again with their ebikes and fireworks.
I have time.
I can get Prism in here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hey, girl.
And we have synergy, too.
I think this shift gave me carpal tunnel.
See, look at that.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Um, where should we search, guys?
Probably a combo type deal.
I chat.
Search the pier, beach, or what?
Oh, yeah, thank God he's normal, too.
Water?
No sign of them?
Where else should we go?
Beach.
Oh.
He could.
Oh, my God.
It was intelligence and charisma.
Are you fucking...
kidding oh he's she's dead she's dead no she's dead we are not weird i did not know oh yeah no no we're not she's not coming back how is i supposed to know you need intelligence i thought we were searching someone
be cool be cool don't do drugs go to school stay in school kids oh my god i could be wrong i fear the teenagers were mocking me uh well you're not exactly cool man impossible my body temperature is always properly oh my god i said like the two non-cool people
See, combat.
Oh, I'll put you in combat.
I can't go on.
Not like this.
Just because a couple of teenagers made...
Oh, no, that's true.
No, never mind.
No, it's understandable.
No, teenagers are really mean people.
No, I get it.
I get it.
Why no more combat?
I'm calling.
Nothing.
It's up combat.
Imagine more combat.
Kids are cruel.
They're so mean.
Bring your heel back from down.
Oh, nice.
Wait, they never really...
Oh, I guess I can bring him back from depression.
Charisma.
He needs more charisma.
Maybe...
That's right.
More charisma.
Anyone but sonar.
Oppo, give it to sonar.
Good week, everybody.
See you all on Monday.
I mean, the Sardine's a villain bar.
Not sure I'd fit in.
Just go dress like that.
Everyone will just think you're a pervert.
What?
Yeah, um, good.
Oh,
we're hitting it.
with the boys let's go oh this looks like a a very non-villain bar oh look he has his airpods on damn big oh you want to drink you want to sure oh that sucks for him hey creep creep i don't know you and i don't like not knowing people well you won't like knowing him he's the biggest perv and he's with us she's joking I'm not my business but if you do go jerking off in the bathroom oh shit make it my business that's I don't want to be in that business is this a villain bar the fuck are we the villain bar after being heroes is there no hero bar no there is a hero bar I guess it'd be cheaper too.
I feel like also it's that's so stupid.
Why the fuck are they here so?
Can they not just get arrested?
I guess they need a warrant to be in the villain bar.
Buy me a drink.
Oh, yeah, no, but my but they don't know my secret identity.
I have my shower patch kids on our first date.
I figure whiskey makes sense for the second.
She called it a day.
You can buy me dinner.
Nothing too far.
I had a good time.
I hadn't been to the movies in a while.
I had a good time eating popcorn too loud while I sat silently next to you.
The silence was the best part.
I forgot if that baby got banned.
You might like it loud sometime.
Was that about sex?
Catch on quick.
I'll grab us a table.
Yeah, because I was saying a Mega Man got banned, but not Robert Robertson.
Make it three.
Four.
Oh my god, bitch, you black forever.
This I recognize the bar Shitty whiskies we should have avoided him earlier.
He thought he was a fucking man.
I recognize this bar that he reminded me of my ex and he's got buzzkill ass energy Been doing this live how long have you been going out like this since day one?
Don't act surprised you were the bad guy until Wait, when did we decide you wasn't the bad guy?
Yeah, when did we decide?
Cheers, I'm here excuse me what you mean temporary blinded but you plan forever i'm thankful that our breakup has given me time say the line unfortunately what i've learned is that i hate me oh good be honest am i going to make a fool of myself if i sing whitney houston are you whitney houston no then yeah you will who will be with
Wait, um, it's kind of hard for me, but look, I know it was probably a buy the books bottom line kind of decision, but thanks.
No problem.
You're going to win 2025 early of the year, bro.
He came at that outside.
Fine.
Bro, we're got, you're going to break the cycle.
We need him to break the cycle, guys.
Oh, shit.
Everyone thinks I'm a narc.
They can still smell the hero on you.
You're the enemy.
What about depression, then?
What else do they want?
You can buy him drinks.
You can make sure they don't get fired.
You can line him up and blow him one by one, but they're still gonna think you might be the hero that fucked up their life.
People don't think about much when I...
eye blown but i hear what you're saying though i had argued they fucked up their own lives being criminals see that snark just tell him he's a loser he's a loser so it's fine bro oh
i must have died during this fight if he's having ptsd
I'm not done with you, yeah.
I'm just getting warmed up.
Oh,
what the fuck is a neck better?
Dude, that's flammable, bro.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I'm a bitch.
My name's Rama.
Suck your bitch.
Whose name is Rama.
Oh, I didn't even notice that.
I'm a bitch.
I'm such a fucking bitch.
I have no hopes, I have no dreams It's Annie Little P And it doesn't even function anyway Because I have your act of dysfunction It's so catchy, guys I thought they lost it working in a deli or something And there was this incident in crypto Where he was fucking with me And I kind of...
I've been dealing with that wistly-ass tooth Because of you Well, it was self-inflicted But I'm not sure he'll see it that way So you can see I'm worried about getting incinerated.
That's how catchy it is.
Oh, yeah, because he doesn't know.
He used to be.
He doesn't know it's mechamand.
Sooner we get a fresh start.
You heard me when I said incinerated, right?
Who let a loser ass bitch of a hero into our supervillain bar?
Why is everyone?
Do I look like a bitch?
Don't answer that.
Fuck.
Is he big?
He's got big guy voice.
Some parts of him are big.
From now on, team drinks are exclusively at Chili's.
Are you lost or something, bitch?
or you're trying to get up what happened to his eyes why is he not a bar is around here for why'd you pick this one you got a death wish homie well since you twisted my arm no one's talking to you you're talking to you bro see they finally gave you some arms they can reach your dick there's some people that want to talk to you if it's a bitch that's a good one
what why are they all glowing red all this like argumentations did all these guys have the same
argumentations yeah try this thanks
what the fuck how did they all get hit i am happy to provide these inauthentic mexican calories for the team to reach off.
Oh, you got the red ring gang?
Did they all have to Xbox get a red ring?
Oh, Jesus, Charlie.
I ordered three triple crunch tacos.
They're all buffed by Charlotte.
Oh, my God, my people are...
Oh, oh, oh!
Wait, why was that censored?
she temporarily blinded me what you mean temporarily big you blind boy she said to lie no i didn't order that i ordered three three triple crunch tacos yeah you've muttered it 50 times just eat that it's the same shit anyway you're lying forever this place is just a remix of the same five ingredients hot sauce say the lie boy and cussed i'd go with both or do some friendly fire
What do you mean temporary planet?
Bitch, you plan forever.
Oh!
They all united with their Xbox getting the red ring of death.
Oh,
shit.
You wash your hands.
after touching all them filthy nutsacks.
Tarty seems salty.
Ooh, there she is.
Thanks, babes.
Smells it up for me and everything.
I think you're looking for these.
Oh, there's the crunch tacos.
This special move.
There we go.
Oh, bro.
Bro, that's some strong-ass teeth.
That's a strong fucking...
It's just doing some sugar, you know?
Is there a fucking penis drawn there?
That's what I'm saying.
Why can't I fucking romantic?
Oh, shit.
enjoying yeah that's right
oh oh my god rip the arm rip it rip it yeah oh oh you should just rift it both arms y'all are fucked up weird thing is how easy it was this churro isn't as soft as his noodle arms yeah his arms Fucking Fanny.
Next time you want to start a fight.
I want another drink.
You're heroes now.
Heroes don't start fights.
You finish them.
Ugh.
That's so fucking corny.
Well, not many finished fights against the Red Ring.
Yeah, how do you have beef with them, Mr. Dispatcher?
Yeah, we know this Robert guy is affluent.
Who are you?
Really?
I'm Robert.
It's a rare thing in life.
You know, fresh start, clean slate.
You all know, every room you walk into, your reputation proceeds.
I walked into SDN, and suddenly I was me.
It was just me.
Big decision!
I'm Robbie.
I'm not sure if you were five years ago, two months ago, yesterday.
No, I saw the other options.
I just want to be Robbie.
Right now, I'm Robert.
Toki, no.
That was it.
That was a big decision.
It's a mind game.
A ticking tactic.
Who are you?
I just told you.
You're the heroes now.
What?
What do you mean?
It was the first thing I went instinct.
What's your problem?
I don't like not knowing things that might make me mad if I knew them.
I'm Robin.
Just let it go, bro.
Be free.
I did.
It was Mega Man and Robin.
And I was like, I'm Robin.
Chad you heard it I'm Chad it's such a it's a big choice hi Chad um my name's Courtney look see we're all doxing ourselves now nice to meet you Courtney look it's so cute was the name given to me on my planet when I first arrived on earth the ladies at the Nordstrom rack I worked that called me dumpy due to my large posterior wait really you may call me either my name's victor because i'm a winner i'm alice bruno ah malevolah my last name's gib my name's call him so what now orgy time right make a fuego sauce and ass play sounds like a great combo good point Anybody have another packet of that stuff?
I like how everyone's like, biggest decision right now!
And I'm like, I'm Robbie.
Whoops.
I just want to be Robbie.
Look, see?
Everyone's happy, guys.
Everyone's so happy.
I don't,
I don't, I don't, I don't.
Sounds like hip-hop, but it's not.
Yeah.
It's like a run DMC.
You know, they came through a wall, but there's a different song.
I hate the world today.
You're so good to me.
I know that I can change.
I can't change.
Yeah, you can change.
I tried to tell you, but you look at me like maybe.
You and 17%.
Oh, that doesn't sound great.
I just want to be robbing.
Oh,
Chase, do we feel sharp?
Okay, but like, do you want to watch the same playthrough of someone not being robbing?
Or do you want to watch the 17%?
Send the ground team, save the Terrence, held your own against...
Yay!
no dreams and a tiny little thing and it doesn't even function any way because every records function it's that will take me yeah just tiny little bitch have my hand now yeah rest assured that when i start to make you nervous and i'm going to extremes tomorrow i will change and today won't mean i think poetry i'm a bitch Thank you,
the boy.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for playing Doki.
I really enjoyed watching you play Dispatch.
This is my first ever Super chat.
So it's only right to go to my first ocean.
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, go.
I'm glad you guys have been having a fun time watching.
I'm gonna have to call it, call it here though.
I actually have to call it here now.
But we did do a lot.
Oh my gosh, I almost went to the next episode just for instinct.
But don't worry, we will complete it.
We will complete it.
Next week, we'll complete the last three episodes.
Next week but thank you all for watching i've been having a really fun time playing dispatch i hope my playthrough has been very enjoyable so far with me uh me being rabbi i think you want a super chat thank you thank you i'm glad you're playing this game it just lets me know what not to do thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so i know um i know there's three more episodes So we will finish it next week.
Maybe on Tuesday.
We'll do it either Tuesday or Monday.
But thank you all for watching, everyone.
I am going to get my third monitor fixed up now.
Well, not... Well, I have a third monitor, but I'm going to go install my third monitor after this stream.
Hey, Jakarta.
Thank you.
Here's to Robert.
That was a very fun way to enjoy my birthday weekend.
I can't wait for the next one.
You play Dispatching of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Doki, you're an itch and your name is Robert.
You gotta live with this.
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Patroescu, thank you, my super chat.
I knew you wouldn't make the correct choices to piss off everyone in chat.
You are the best Doki to ever punish.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean the wrong choices?
These were the choices that vibe with me the most.
I thought they were great choices, guys.
wonderful picks for the most interesting experience guys we're not here to do like the same gameplay that ever the same gameplay the boring goody two shoes decisions we're here to do things that are fun anyway as always everybody say hydrated posture check get up and move around and get that blood flowing and if you suffer me head to bed cause you deserve of it i'll see you guys next time everybody paul thank you the super chat thank you thank you with huge voter turnout in the chat we should petition for phenomenon sonar romance path as downloadable content full of non-stop hugging surely then man pat will win for me at the year thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that's what i'm saying why can't i romance this is the perfect harem game i would say i swear season two does not give me a harem then This game would have been so much more popular if we could have romanced everyone in our team.
Why does he have to be 100% straight?
He could be a little bit curious.
That's all I'm saying.
Like, being surrounded with all these superheroes and super villains?
I mean, so true.
You could be a little curious.
I mean, what's that game called?
The Dungeons and Dragons game.
That was that one game of the year.
Everyone loved that game because you could romance everyone.
That's why it was so popular.
I swear to God, if that game doesn't restricted the romancing, the game would not have one game of the year, chat.
Baldur's Gate.
If Baldur's Gate 3 restricted who you could romance, it would not have one game of the year.
I should be allowed to romance everyone.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.